[Music]
thank you
hey everybody what's going on it is a
little bit bright but oh well what are
you gonna do it looked okay earlier so
we're just gonna leave it like this
that's all I gotta say
but hey how's everybody doing uh thank
you everybody for the birthday wishes uh
my birthday is Tuesday so I'm guessing
we'll probably I mean we'll we'll do a
Monday night stream like a movie review
like we usually do so that's closer but
this is like the Side Tracks that's
closest to the birthday yeah she won't
be here for the birthday thing she's
going to be visiting her brothers and
sisters well I'll be here Monday night
Monday yeah but um the Wednesday night
show I think I mentioned this on
the last show that we did on Wednesday
night
um probably the normal Wednesday night
show this week I'm probably gonna move
it till Thursday because I'm probably
not going to be home on Wednesday in
time to do the show
so we're probably moving to Thursday I
don't know what the topic is going to be
yet because the poll just went up this
morning and the poll doesn't close until
Sunday so that's how we find out how the
[__] is Camp guy said two of the
craziest stories I've heard lately uh
Larry Ray and the Sarah Lawrence College
Girl case I have not heard of that and
the worst uh Munchausen Syndrome uh
story I've ever heard Gypsy Rose
Blanchard I think that we did a show
about her
or I think we did a show not entirely
about her but I think we did like a
Munchausen by proxy type thing or like
cases like that and she was one of the
ones we talked about I thought I don't
remember that that was the one with um
yeah because he just said it's like the
the mom made Gypsy Rose right around in
a wheelchair even though she could walk
and told her she had muscular dystrophy
like in all those other diseases I think
so yeah and then didn't didn't the
daughter end up uh killing the mom like
with her and her boyfriend something
like or something like that it was a
crazy yeah I think we talked about it
how long did it take her to figure out
is there was nothing wrong with her
I think she was a teenager wow you know
what I mean can you imagine
yeah Camp guy said he would put a
healthy kid in a wheelchair and tell him
they couldn't walk crazy people that too
yeah total that but that's a thing 1,000
by proxy I'm just saying if if the
doctor [__] did that to her she
deserved what she got yeah it's like I
honestly I think when we talked about
the story I was just kind of like yeah I
don't really Advocate murder or anything
like that but it's like yeah she kind of
had it coming yeah yeah the white man's
law wouldn't approve of it but I don't
care what the white man's law says most
of the time
Camp guy said yeah her mom got her as a
poster child for the Special Olympics
yeah yeah she told her she had all kinds
of diseases and she didn't know any
different than to remain I guess
uh Zach's uh also says telling me happy
birthday so thank you very much uh for
that said he had a gig Sunday shooting a
music video oh that's pretty cool yeah
tell us about that
on Monday that would be cool
so yeah it's Friday night we're just
here it's coming hanging out having a
drink yeah we're [__] stay at home
we're broke man we're [__] broke I
think we're broke you know well we'll
see yeah we'll see we had a couple uh
good nights
[__] doing our side projects in the
past three days just [__] all seems
like all traffic just vanished
yeah it's been really weird and it's not
just us it's not everybody us it's like
everybody is having a hard time like
over over on stream mate yeah
so we had a good night and then it shut
down the next day we had like we made
like 85 bucks in about two and a half
hours yeah not even not even about two
hours yeah yeah and [__] and we were
like woo yeah yeah tomorrow we're gonna
make a [__] time we're gonna make 150
and there was like nothing yeah there
was like nobody there
you just sit there live and nobody comes
in one guy comes in and he leaves yeah
and it's like not even because if you
when you when you do it it's like you
can see your little chat window right
and you can see like when somebody who's
a member that's like signed in like when
they come in the room it's like boinking
like it makes a noise and like their
name comes up but if there are people
looking at your Channel or your room
from outside from outside and they're
not members you can see you can't see
their names or nothing but you can see
how many of them there are well you can
also you can also it's also members who
press the screen and don't go in but
just it starts to move right like I do
so yeah so you have like like the
preview of what's going on yeah they
can't hear you but they're you're a
little small icon yeah but they're
seeing what you're doing in there yeah
they're they're waiting for something
wait for you to get active or whatever
but uh just foot track we call it foot
traffic because it's like being in a
damn store dick traffic
little dicks coming by yeah
so uh anyway the uh
traffic just [__] died man and uh so
I go through so I'm seeing who else is
in our region which is the
English-speaking region
there's all these babes of [__] all
different ages ranging from like 18 to
60 and and yeah they do have some babes
on there they're like 58 59 there are
yes yeah they look real good and they're
they get busy they got they got a lot of
[__] fans the young guys
and I'm scrolling through there to see
what everybody's doing and they're all
just looking bored as [__] we're calling
their balloons and [__] yeah some girls
are [__] on all fours trying to shake
their ass and just spinning the damn
trying to get you to spin the wheel
nothing and then you at the very bottom
of the list you can see who's in shows
at any one time and
out of 300 270
babes a lot of them pop most of them huh
at about 270 of them there might be only
10 of them in a show at any one time yes
that's [__] which means the traffic
is the traffic is very slow yeah which
is bad yeah and they're on and you see
like nearly three of them 300 of them
online at once which means everybody's
hurting for money so they're all in
there at once do work in the worst hours
yeah you know what I mean like which is
middle of the day here
you know but they're just working long
long hours and usually you know
it kind of comes in spurts in in our
time zone for some reason morning's
really good because uh you can pick up I
guess England is late at night there
well it's not late at night but it's
like later afternoon yeah so
you'll get British customers early
and then
between eight and one you'll get more
American customers
getting later but it's it's worldwide
though if it's weird it comes but then
like the
the that
seems like and it's just not me you know
I'll talk to Bill about it because his
his wife is [__] streaming constantly
not only on that platform on a whole
bunch of other ones
she'll jump she'll jump on other ones
but they're token sites and I hate those
yeah
um
which there's a lot of it's in public
yeah I don't want to do that yeah [__]
that and then um but it's like
that uh
like nine o'clock until
eight is kind of dead
yeah yeah right or no 12. but probably
around 12 huh 10 yeah 12 10 11 to about
eight is pretty dead
like just weird I don't understand it
yeah we're supposed to be worldwide so I
don't know
me and Bill were talking about we think
that maybe streammate is somehow gaming
algorithms
yeah maybe
they might be doing it because they
don't have bandwidth Maybe
well we have noticed that it didn't
happen today because we were on for a
few hours today but
um our camera goes black sometimes yeah
and at first we thought it was the
camera it's not this camera we actually
use a different camera for that because
the other camera has a light on it
but um I was just noticing that every
now and then like it would just go dark
like they could people could still hear
us but it went dark and a couple times
it happened like in the middle of a show
and I was just like well [__] that's not
good yeah lots of money yeah
um but I now I don't think it's the
camera I think it's them yeah because
sometimes their shit's like real glitchy
like if you you can um go like Tom will
go in there to see who else is on or see
how like what the competition is and
stuff and we'll go on there and he'll be
like okay well how many people are
streaming in
you know the English-speaking region and
it's like it'll say like 25 people and
I'm just like that that's impossible
because usually it's kind of it's
usually around 200 between 200 and 300
that's generally like what it is
um at whatever time that you check
they're saying everybody's broke well
you know Dynamics
yeah
because I'm a sex industry
well nobody has extra money
well I haven't had extra money since
2016 so you know what I mean yeah yeah
actually actually I haven't had extra
money since way before that many people
with extra money so I don't know if it's
anything to do with that I think that's
just like a steady decline since the
[__] 1970s bro yeah yeah it is but
it's just kind of like uh yeah I I
haven't had I haven't had uh extra money
for yeah decades yeah so I don't think
that's a new thing well they sent all
the jobs abroad
yeah
Zach said he went to the bath house
again played it smart this time only had
soreness in places that don't make sense
as a consequence said it actually is
impressive how many muscles you don't
realize you use when banging someone
next day it's like why is my neck stiff
and why do I have tennis elbow in my
knees
and then the other dude you're doing
this
Tom knows exactly what was going on yeah
my mind I see it
in your mind yeah
[Laughter]
that's [__] yeah cheating on me Zach
oh yeah
[__] is ruining my Gavin Friday song
me and you up in the [__] penthouse
in a bubble bath with all the with all
the dudes with like angel wings age
wings and [__] all around yeah Jan's got
the camera [__] bubbles [__]
bubbles [__] boys bubble machine pink
balloons heart heart shaped tub hell
yeah 360 degree view
oversea in Las Vegas
yeah it's got to be lost yes Kevin
Friday's angel that song playing yeah
yeah if you've seen yeah if you've seen
bazlerman's uh Romeo and Juliet yeah
that's the song I'm talking about that
Tom loves that song I Love It song so I
put it that's the only good that
grabbing Friday song just that one yeah
sweet I don't like any of this other
[__]
yeah that's a good one I even put it on
that I put it on the playlist on on
Tom's playlist yeah so you'll hear that
and then you'll hear like [__] juice
pretty slick right after that I removed
her head or something
I have
remember we heard it in the car I don't
remember Motorhead
heart-shaped vibrating bed yeah exactly
that's kind of what I'm uh that's what
I'm picturing that's what I'm picturing
Camp guy said I'll be starting to draw
Social Security checks in about a week
or so ooh lucky I'm just kind of like I
even looked the other day because I
don't even know what the age is now I
was like when can I get when can I get
Social Security am I old enough no I'm
not I probably have to I think it's
isn't it 65 or 64.
for women I don't even remember what it
is so I'm just like oh my God that's
still like [__] 15 years away or like
it just seems like such a long time I'm
like really I have to like scrape
together enough money to live like until
I get that and I won't even get that
much because
I think it's um because isn't Social
Security don't they take like an average
of your what is it you're 10 or 12
highest paid years
isn't that what they do and then that
and Social Security I don't know and
then that's what they give you like
monthly and I was like well I never
really made all that much money so
yeah Camp guy said I just turned 62 the
absolute youngest you can start oh okay
yeah still
[__]
okay I'm gonna go apply
seven years well yeah that's what I mean
it's like you're a lot like closer than
I am yeah I think you get less if you go
in early like if you wait till you're 65
I think that you get the full amount but
I think if you go 62 like they don't
yeah that's what camp guy said you take
a reduced benefit that young yeah
we're kind of hoping that uh that VA
benefit goes that yours goes up because
you should marry get married yeah should
go a couple hundred bucks I mean we went
online and yeah and put me as a
dependent yeah
so we'll see how that goes off they're
supposed to send us back I think they
said they were gonna send like something
through the mail like within a week or
something because I think it was just
the other day that we what was what is
it did that somebody gonna fill out
um I think they just said that if they
need any more [__] like if they need to
see like the marriage certificate or if
they need to see like my tax forms or
whatever [__] right then you know
what I mean
yeah murder Hornet said Tom can you get
Social Security and VA benefits yeah you
can yeah I thought everybody got Social
Security and get federal and state like
as long as you had paid into it like
over your working years then yeah I
thought everybody got it you can also
get stuff from your state sometimes I
haven't tried Florida but I'm thinking
about it yeah yeah there's probably some
stuff that the state can give me for
being a disabled veteran yeah
surprise [__] like food stamps but hey
that's less money you've spent on food
that's what I mean I was like [__] man
I'll take it yeah give me that [__]
fans will give you food stamps too but
you gotta apply for them and I don't
really quite know how to do it I gotta
start playing that VA system it's Rife
it's it's filled to the brim with money
uh [__] that's what I mean they got
money make them give you the military
industrial complex all of it is a
[__] grift
the US military is a grift [__]
officer Corps total [__] grift
um all the [__] military academies
grift
and uh all the [__] support
businesses that are around it it's all
grift we have a huge [__] military
budget and
everything's like [__] second or
third rate because most of it goes to
all that grift and all that [__] pay
and uh going to
I mean there's [__] I think there's
like 400 generals and like 200 100 and
something of them or four star generals
yeah you know what I mean those dudes
are getting hundreds of thousands of
dollars a month and you don't need that
many generals
but they got to have some place to put
all these
funky rich kids that's all they are
funky rich kids that's the from families
they were they were the flunkies from
Rich families that make them a general
John Gore said they need to see the sex
streams
they're not going to see gonna see too
much in public like I said we don't do
all that much in public yeah you just
got it
so you got you got a paper you gotta pay
you gotta pay you gotta go go private or
I mean unless somebody that paid like
recorded that [__] somehow and then like
sold it somewhere I mean I guess people
could find it then but I don't think so
well we have videos now yeah that too
you you can buy it you know eventually
everything leaks but
we didn't do the video to make money we
do video to make money yeah mostly just
did video to get street cred right
yeah well I mean you know well they they
take a little bit longer to make but
yeah we got to go make some more we
gotta make some more eventually yeah
Jenny's [__] looking really good so
her new figure is [__] killer the
legs are getting really [__] good man
I was looking we were on um we were on
streamate today and we kind of had like
a normally we'd sit in the chairs but we
had like a kind of little palette on the
floor today because we were trying out
some different [__] and uh I'm looking
at the [__]
Monitor and I'm sitting there going oh
my God that doesn't even look like my
leg anymore yeah because it's like so
much thinner yeah it's real lean I was
like whose leg is that
that's starting to see a bunch of
muscles in it it's like so weird it was
so weird that it's like looked like
somebody else she's changing so quickly
the Skin's having a hard time keeping up
with the with the structural changes
that are happening there she's losing a
lot of fat building a lot of muscle yeah
I mean yeah hopefully it'll sort itself
out yeah it will hopefully it wouldn't
normally
but you're
endocrine system isn't normal right now
so everything is working at an
accelerated rate
like three times what a teenage girl
would be doing yeah
and all that progesterone in there too
kind of works as testosterone for women
I was testing a testosterone like
analog substance called natural law
and natural produces a lot of it
progesterone which doesn't really do a
whole lot in guys but in women it's
looking they'd blossom in it
that's part of it what makes it real
feminine looking
feminine
and strong kind of look which is a weird
combination
you know you can't replicate a teenage
girl's metabolisms and then you can't
accelerated to like three times what a
teenage girl is that she would be crazy
crazy as [__] you couldn't do it
and she would probably get really fat
probably would because the no one wants
to be the hormonal profile is kind of
odd so you have to kind of move in
another Direction more towards
progesterone yeah which is what you'd
use in birth control pills but it's
mixed with
19 North testosterone
Zach says that reminds me I weighed
myself earlier 202 back in April I was
almost 230. damn you fat well he just
said I hope I don't go back to 155 ever
again that was too skinny for me yeah
how tall well he's uh five foot nine
it's perfect yeah yeah 155 is to uh thin
for a five foot nine years probably I
would think yeah that seems like it for
a dude about 180 right now
180 at five six and about 11 percent
11 somewhere between 11 and 13 body fat
which is pretty lame yeah
I only have love handles now and a
little and you don't even really have
that what do you really used to do right
oh yeah
you never I don't think I don't they
were never that bad
uh I know you're very you were kind of
like I always wanted to detail about it
I always wanted yeah I didn't like
having to blocky upper body I like I
wanted to have like a classic physique
like from the 60s 50s and the 60s that
[__] wasp waste that you know like
Arnold
real [__] little waste but you can
get that you just have to do a lot of
deadlift
gear and just pile a lot of [__]
muscle onto your upper body and you'll
kind of get that
V taper it takes time especially at my
age
yeah well
you go like I said you got to think that
most people your age are not doing what
you're doing so I'm not gonna get where
I want actually I'm not gonna get where
I want to go until probably about
another two or three years
yeah and I'll be a lot closer to where I
wanted to be
I'm what
how many years in am I not HRT but just
gear two years maybe I think maybe two
years maybe maybe not even that long
maybe not even that long it might be 18
months huh
because you started at the at the test
Clinic when we were still at the house
still Sanford at the old house I started
gear here
yeah and we've only been at this house
for
less than two years okay so it might
have been about 18 months I think we
moved in right yeah because we moved
right around my birthday yeah so we're
coming up on two years that we've been
in this house
which is crazy yeah it seemed like we
just [__] moved here that's how fast
[__] goes when you start [__] with
HRT and gear at my age
you see a difference in it in a year
easily
you saw it you saw it in a year yeah
um you saw with just test in in a couple
years it actually tests you can see the
difference in about six months I would
think you felt better instantly you did
I didn't yeah I remember yeah I was just
[__] man I was like oh I forgot what
this felt like yeah I'm a man
God I want it I want a piece of that ass
[__] look at Jen hold me back
let's go let's go [__] this chick I'm
like a damn [__] dog in heat man
you're just going back you were like
that for a while yeah then you kind of
then then it kind of normalizes again
you get used to it but when you haven't
had it although you're still kind of
like that now well that's because gear
yeah yeah although I'm kind of like that
yeah
that's the same thing to wear
okay remember that bodybuilder Chelsea
that I showed you yeah you should hear
her talking on her [__]
she's on a lot of [__] you know she's on
basically male level
protocols and she just just talked about
what a sex machine she is yeah that she
says I'm worse than a teenage boy much
worse yeah she says if I want you I'm
gonna [__] you
because you're probably not strong
enough to stop well damn that's a little
threatening yeah arms are huge
oh man [__] most dudes are like okay
okay all right well yeah it's whatever
you want it's not as threatened this is
the other way around yeah she's a cute
girl they've sent me up like a dude said
that I'd be like oh my God I have him
arrested nah she can get what she wants
and she's talking about Gym Rats right
she's talking about down in the gym
right and those dudes are up for that
they're like yeah okay man
yeah I'll be at your house come on
but I mean it well it's kind of good
because you know since we have since
we've been doing streaming you have to
do it for that long it's you kind of
have to be sort of into it or
because you know a lot of us people our
age would not be able to keep up with
that pace
with normal endocrine system of the 50s
that's why that's why those older senior
porn stars look the way that they do
yeah because they're not normal
yeah a lot of stuff
Camp guy says my wife and I always lived
paycheck to paycheck and now that I'm
older my parents passed away I inherited
a bunch of property and now we old and
retired but we can buy [__] yeah that's
awesome you make enough money to cover
the taxes because yeah I guess free
taxes so [__] if you don't have any
money because he was saying earlier he
was like I'm rich [__]
some states that's good especially up in
the Northeast purposely trying to [__]
people over like uh there was
my buddy Eric who I went to Army with
dating a girl who was friends with
another girl who was from I think Newton
which is a rich neighborhood he's either
Newton or Wellesley
her parents got killed in a car wreck
yikes she inherited everything but it
was like a multi-million dollar estate
[__] big pieces of property and
everything
she didn't have enough income to even
pay the property tax they took
everything from her she lost everything
ain't that some [__]
well that's what I mean it's just kind
of like that's super [__] that's why I
would not like because you know how they
have these you know periodically they'll
have these contests was like would you
win this million dollar house I'm like
yeah no thank you it's like why don't
you just give me a million dollars how
about that yeah it's like I don't want
to deal with that [__] mess she tried
to put that property up for sale and it
wouldn't sell because everybody knew
right everybody knew all I had to do is
wait it out and she would lose that [__]
and you could get it and then get it for
a super cheap that's [__] up yep
yeah I wouldn't really get into
property or anything like that it's just
it's more trouble than it's worth you
know it sounds like the properties and
where it is yeah it depends on where it
is because it's there's no guarantee
that you're ever gonna be able to sell
it
I kind of like uh Tim Poole what Tim
Poole did he's a I don't know if you
know who he is he's a famous YouTuber
he got big or he's a little skateboard
beanie half Korean guy who started
basically having his own little news
channel and he was doing he's an
investigative reporter I think he came
from uh
uh uh he came from Vice that's where he
came from back when Vice was good
he moved out in the middle of nowhere he
but he was one of these guys that made a
[__] ton of [__] ad revenue on
YouTube you know he had millions of
subscribers he he bought a [__]
compound
uh you know I think it's like a
three-story house the big compound it's
got chicken coops and farms and he's got
a lot of his friends living with him
running the farm they're like they're
damn near Off the Grid they're making
their own food and [__] and uh he just
streams from there
and uh he flies in
basically celebrity guests they're
online celebrities you know and flies
them in and they'll [__] do they'll
they'll stream for a couple days
straight because he has so many spare
rooms they could just stay with him yeah
and he you know he's basically running
like a like a little news channel he you
know kind of like Vice like he's running
it from his
house and I think it was Virginia's you
correct me if I'm wrong I think it was
Virginia but he bought that [__] for
next to nothing big piece of property
big house on it well yeah I mean if
you're willing to live out in the middle
of nowhere then yeah obviously you can
get [__] for a lot cheaper than if you
want to live somewhere and it's all paid
for he was able to pay for it off you
know within a few years
and I think it's got a [__] airstrip
so people can land private airplanes and
[__] no so that's pretty cool man yeah
yeah
Zach says uh definitely worrying about
my folks at the moment mom's still sick
Dad's not working yet and we might have
money issues involving our house and I
don't have a backup plan in case [__]
goes tits up here yeah that's the thing
I uh
I try to have backup plans but for some
reason nothing ever works out you know
what I mean
so I don't know
like I said I'm still we're still doing
streamate we haven't you know I've been
kind of freaking out a little bit just
because the last couple days have been
really bad like we only picked up
like we did really good one night and
then like the next day there was like
nobody and I think we made like four
bucks or something like we weren't on
all day or anything but we were on for
like several hours and I was like [__]
this there's like nobody here and um so
I don't know I'm still like applying for
you know remote work like graphic design
stuff and stuff because I was like well
at least I I have another skill like
something else that I can do but even
then it's like that's
Brill Hit or Miss because there's so
much competition yeah but today you got
to be real [__] flexible you got to
have a lot of different [__] fires
burning we got a lot of income streams
but they don't make much money you need
a lot right and that's what I mean and
it's so I have to keep track of like all
of these million yeah little bitty
things every now that it's like 100 here
a couple hundred dollars there [__] like
that but it's just kind of like it's
it's exhausting like keeping up you
probably forget to check some of that
[__] too I probably do yeah
um yeah they're talking about temple
being an ass and [__] that he's an
army
um Tim pulls a milk toast fat sitter
during all that
during that last election if you've
said anything that YouTube didn't like
that they'd [__] yank your uh your
your uh your monetization so he had to
be real careful about what he said
so he had to back off and everything he
would sound real neutral for a long time
but
that's just the problem with YouTube
well I can't really say what's on your
mind you can get you can lose your [__]
you know we lose income we lose income
just by doing a lot of these serial
killer shows because I will speak our
minds about it and we'll use keywords
that the AI algorithms will [__]
it'll yank about it yeah a lot of our a
lot of our videos are they're
demonetized or not yeah and I can't
believe this channel is still running
with some of the [__] that I said I
would have thought that the [__]
whole chat will be taken down nah we
don't like I said really the only thing
that happens is
you know about 50 of the time like it's
limited ad revenue or they don't give
any AD Revenue because it's usually like
a like a serial killer topic or
something like that
um so we do have that happen like I said
I've only ever had one copyright strike
and it was [__] and I fought it and
they they could and they and they put it
back up because it was [__] yeah it
was [__] Sharknado no it was the mag
team and they took the video down yeah
and we gave it a good review didn't make
any [__] sense well like I said that
wasn't YouTube that was Warner Brothers
so I bitched and I was just kind of like
what the [__] we didn't even say
anything on there like we didn't use any
footage they put it back up yeah because
I was like don't you don't you [__] with
me the bag two I thought was better than
the mag
um it was just a good
theater movie just a big dumb big dumb
action which reminds me Expendables 4
started today it did but uh we can't
really afraid I know I'm too broke to go
see it
we just watched actually uh after the
other show the other night we watched
what do we watch part three
yeah okay that was part three I adapters
I definitely had not seen that one
before it was it was directors cut of
part three I don't think I saw the
second one either because you said the
second one had Chuck Norris in it and I
was just like I'm sure that I didn't see
the Chuck Norris one I must have only
seen the first one then some people
didn't like uh
Expendables three uh but I
evidently the theatrical cut isn't that
good I've never seen anything it was all
right
I've never seen a theatrical cup I've
only seen the director's cup
that's what we watched
I liked it John Gore said my backup plan
is dying
yeah we're in the same boat I think
that's just kind of like it's depressing
but I mean I try I keep trying to do
[__] but
you know
when you have a couple of days where
you're just kind of like okay we we have
like a goal
every day we need to make this amount of
money and when you don't even like get
close to it
I start flipping out a little bit I
start flipping out a little bit not
gonna lie so
I don't know I'm just I'm trying not to
flip out I'm just trying to be like oh
well you know tomorrow's another day and
maybe [__] will be different and stuff
like that but we'll see we'll see
um Zach says there's a cool looking
movie coming out soon called All of Us
Strangers Like a romantic ghost story
movie about these two dudes who hook up
and one of them talking with his parents
ghosts I kind of want to see it that
does sound kind of cool actually
uh John Boris also says I watched Roman
polanski's frantic the other night great
movie had the proper brutal cynicism and
romantic sweetness of Noir I don't think
I've ever seen that I've seen most of
his movies but I don't think I've ever
seen that one or if I did I didn't
remember it I must have seen it a long
time ago but that's another one that
I'll probably have to
revisit you know what I mean
[Laughter]
so you know
uh let's see what else can we
talk about
Tom spacing out nah scratching his beard
becoming more wise
I've got that [__] light up too high
but I'm just gonna leave it there yeah
because I noticed that that's not
normally that's not normally there
that's not normally where it is I was
tripping we usually have it like right
yeah I don't know what you were I had an
erection at the time you did I know
it was and it was stuck in all your
brain power yeah yeah well what we were
trying to do
this morning
is Thomas like well he's like I want to
try and experiment where he's like I'm
just gonna he's like I'll still be in
the room and everything but I'm gonna be
off camera he's like because he wanted
to see if the traffic would be better if
it was just me yeah we just had just a
picture of her so we just did like the
photo of me instead of both of us they
were coming in there asking where I was
yeah and then so that I was like well
that didn't work I guess well that's
because I think it's because the name of
the Damn Channel too well yeah that is
one so they knew yeah because somebody
came in and because Tom's like well you
know just when they come in just like
flirt with them and stuff but then they
were all asking it's like oh you know
can you have and and then like the one
guy asked me he's like well are you
alone and I was like yeah and then he's
like oh that's too bad like where is it
he's like I I wanted to see you know I'm
not gonna like elaborate but it's like
he wanted to see that and I was like
yeah and I was like oh okay well he's
there so you know what I mean so we did
that but yeah it was just kind of funny
that it's just kind of I guess
everyone's just gotten used to like
because I don't know I don't look at the
site myself like I don't I'm not a
member of it and then I look at it
really recognize us so yeah so I think
that everybody's kind of used to because
even the one guy came in and he's just
like well what you know I even though it
was just me he was like well what are
the protocols like what what do you guys
do like on the couple cams so I think
that
um
so most people are kind of expecting it
to be two people yeah we were wondering
sometimes that kind of helps in some
ways because it
if you go in there and searching for
couples in our in our
in our region the English region you're
we're only going to have one or two
other couples there so right there's
only three on at one time yeah and then
there might be a fourth one and that's
going to be two girls or three girls
they had three British girls on there
today yeah there was three of them yeah
they didn't last long though
for some reason traffic wasn't didn't
favor them I don't know why they were
all cute they were all yeah we looked in
there they were just all laying around
like looking at their phones and they
were they were
fives and Eights blondes so that made me
not feel as bad well obviously I still
feel bad because I'm not making any
money but um I was like well nobody else
is making any money either no so it's
not that it's just kind of like ooh we
don't want to look at that girl it was
just like even all the hot chicks were
like sitting there going dude what the
[__] where is everyone where is
everybody
so there was like they were and they
were you know these are early to mid 20s
yeah those three girls
yeah so you know you think that they
would
in a healthy situation I don't know if
it's just stream maybe there's something
wrong with the algorithms or if it's
just the economy normally those girls
would be [__] slammed yeah and I
don't know if it's just like the timing
because it does seem like some days we
go on and like and it's real busy like
people are just coming in and out all
the time and it's like a lot of people
are in shows and yeah [__] like that so
maybe it's just like a weird
I don't know maybe it's just like a
weird time it just kind of comes and
goes it's just really you never know
evidently the the economy in Europe is
really starting to [__] suck that's a
big problem right there
um
the economy is not real great in the
United States
uh it's going state by state
evidently Florida and Texas are still
[__] running strong but a lot of the
other states aren't doing it New York's
not doing too well California's not
doing too well Chicago area is not doing
too well
my dad in Mississippi says he's never
seen Mississippi such a ghost town
and Mississippi's been depressed for 150
years
since the [__] war of Northern
aggression [__] Mississippi has been
[__] up and he says he's never seen it
this bad
yeah [__] spooky
what are you gonna do yeah like I said
just trying to [__]
scrape together a living yeah although
um
the coast is probably doing good though
I mean he's he's Inland he's in central
yeah Mississippi Gulf Coast usually
[__] slammed because of all the uh
casinos
I'm just yeah that's the thing it's just
I don't know it's I've been you know
kind of poor my whole life so it's not
like
I'm not used to it it's just like the
older you get like the more it starts to
suck because you're like really
shouldn't be like this anymore you know
what I mean you get kind of tired of
just constantly like not having money
and it just really blows John says I'd
watch a couple came of a couple just
fighting not getting along
there's I'm sure there's probably like a
niche for that
um we've noticed that there are some
people and I don't really know how
popular these are but they're Deuce
there does seem to be a niche for like
people sleeping
like people watching people sleep
which I get it I guess it's kind of like
a voyeur type of thing but I was like
man I need to get in on that but I don't
know like if they're making any money or
not I think what it is is they have
those tip generated vibrators and I
think they just lay there and sleep and
then somebody tips and like wakes them
up or some [__] like that I'm not really
sure
talking about the new iPhone coming out
today
I didn't even know about that my phone
is so [__] old
I don't even know what my and mine's not
an iPhone anyway mine's like uh what is
mine mine's an LG Stylo and I need to
get a new one too because mine's all
busted up I've dropped it a couple times
the glass is broken like the back is
kind of popped off like that and it just
does glitchy [__] all the time I'm gonna
put some more ice
yeah yeah
but
can't afford it at the moment and it's
still working so at least as far as now
uh John said sleep get paid I could do
that right that's what I'm saying like I
said I don't really know how it's just
something I've noticed and there's this
is really weird too there's this one
girl on there that she looks real young
I mean obviously she has to be over 18.
because they you know they've had
everybody but she doesn't look it she
looks like real young but all we ever
see her doing is just sitting and
looking at the camera she's not like
talking she's not doing anything but she
always seems to be like picked up like
in shows you know what I mean like
because you'll see her for a second like
just in her room just like looking at
the camera and then all of a sudden
she's like
you know hey I'm performing live like
come back later or something like that
and I was like what is she doing in
there I don't like I don't know like I
said I'm still trying to like figure out
we're still trying to figure out like
the best way to
to interact like with the people that
come in because for a while because
Tom's like oh every time somebody comes
in the room you should say hi whatever
your screen name is because it's usually
something like I don't know feet [__]
or something like that and so well not
always but a lot of times we did
so um so for a while I was doing that
but then I noticed that I was like most
people are just coming in and peeking
because they're just like looking in
everybody's rooms like seeing what
everybody's doing so I was like so I
don't know
because I would notice you go hi
whatever your name is like you know big
[__] or whatever and um and then like
they would just leave and so like a lot
of people do that so I'm just kind of
like well I'm gonna start now like
giving people like a 15 second like if
when they come in the room
either they have to say something or
they're still there and then I'll say
something to them because it's like if
you say something as soon as they walk
in then they usually just leave
we've also noticed too another thing
that we've noticed is that if people are
gonna pay you to do something then
they'll usually do it like right away
it's not usually a case where because
the more they start talking
like and they're trying to get you to
say [__] you know what I mean so we've
noticed that a lot of people are doing
that too so
Zach says might have to look for a new
brand Jenny LG doesn't make phones
anymore believe it or not see that's how
[__] old my phone is yeah that phone
takes great pictures though it does well
I think most phones take great pictures
nowadays my tablets don't that's true
photos worth [__] man [__] terrible
photos yeah
you'd think that as big as it is they
could put a good camera in it I guess
not
exactly what I don't know what the
[__] camera yeah what brand is that I
don't even know
um
I don't even know what your tablet is I
don't know LG oh that's what my phone is
okay
yeah but my phone actually I take
pictures I take pictures of galaxies
right there
no Samsung and LG are cheetah okay no
this galaxy then oh Samsung Galaxy yeah
well I used to have a Samsung Galaxy
phone yeah but this was because I have
Cricut and I just picked this one
because it was kind of like the cheapest
one with the most features like when I
was updating but now I need to update
and I can't really afford you at the
moment but so you know
then they're fighting over to Dallas
Alaska yeah I'm just man I thought this
was good
when you go to Korea you're going to see
a swastika everywhere
usually on
um things kind of like uh pharmacies
Korean herbal pharmacies they'll have
that on there it's just it's just
basically the yin yang sign
uh mustache man in the Germans [__]
just co-opted that and if you go back in
history to see what they were looking
for
mustache man was pissed that Russians
had all the good [__] he loved the
hammered sickle he thought that was a
powerful symbol
and that their party needed something
like that so uh he just borrowed an
Eastern symbol
but it made sense for their
movement it symbolized kind of like a
yin yang symbol
it was the axis upon which the world
turned
and later on they were called the Axis
powers you know England Germany Japan so
they were just change it's a solar
symbol
um but people get all bent out of shape
over [__] flags and symbolism it's
all artificial constructs
all built they're all put together by
marketing men who seek power over the
weak-minded so they give them symbols to
obey and to follow
I know I lived it the military is filled
with nothing but symbols to open back up
because pokey's right behind me
cloth will cause you to kill other
people and to kill yourself in the
[__] combat
off in the name of Honor
so uh I don't respect any of them really
uh for the most part they're all fake
fake social constructs by people that
seek power always and there's always
corporate nowadays in the modern worlds
corporations do it
anything that can anything they tell you
anything they give you is some kind of
mechanism or tool of control to control
and manipulate you
um they'll come up with an idea
and try to sell it through corporate
channels in the mass media and you would
think boy those are some good people to
promote such great values and all this
bull the people that are promoting that
don't give a [__] about that
nothing they don't care about gay people
black people white people they don't
care about people at all
they only care about their own money and
their own power and to secure it
don't ever think that anybody cares
about you they don't
not at all if you were to die they would
gain from that
that's how much they own this system
Tammy says off topic saw a sun odd movie
on Amazon Prime called inside starring
Willem Dafoe as an art Thief who gets
stuck in a luxury Penthouse that he was
supposed to be robbing and it's trapped
for quite a while that actually sounds
uh really good I like Willem Dafoe a lot
so I might have to watch that Titanic
discussion says good evening is there
any way you folks could do reaction
videos for movies or have you seen
everything that there is to react to uh
you know we've seen everything well I
mean there is like a lot of ones yeah
but I mean a reaction video would kind
of be different I guess be hard to do
yeah I mean we had thought about it
another thing is that would take a lot
of time there isn't a big monetary
return on that yeah we got to pay bills
around this month 13 o'clock is a
passion project it doesn't really make
money we do not yeah not much but yeah I
mean we do make a little bit of money
for him but not that much but yeah we
just do it because we enjoy doing it
yeah pretty much
um Tom got me into this reaction show
because normally I don't really like
those reaction videos I don't watch a
lot of those but um he got me into
uh what the hell is the name of that
channel
I can't remember the name of the channel
are you looking it up no oh okay do you
remember yeah yeah did you like
villagers react I think it's called
villagers react or something like that
yeah it's just two Pakistani Muslim guys
in their early 20s what's his name
uh
I forgot their names
one of them's name is Mansour masseur
Navid Navid yeah these they're just
great guys
y'all guys they seem really nice they've
never seen any of these classic flicks
like Terminator one Terminator two alien
Back to the Future yeah they I I think
they're listening to
some kind of foreign dub I don't think
they I don't think they're reading
subtitles
um but uh
they're they're real intelligent guys
and evidently from the middle of nowhere
but they
they get it
yeah and uh
it's kind of a testament to old
Hollywood those old movies the writing
was very good
and everything was Universal you know
any human being could understand those
stories and and love those characters I
mean they were getting into Ripley from
[__] alien they just thought she was
the greatest like a good person you know
boy she braved you know yeah uh just
which you know uh they became Arnold
Schwarzenegger fans yeah just
yeah 80s stuff for at least 80s and 80s
stuff really spoke to them but they
watched Shrek they laughed at that they
showed them um
well they showed another group of guys
the new uh uh Wednesday Addams they like
that yeah it's just it's better to watch
reaction videos to all classic stuff
from young people that come from
cultures that are totally alien to the
question that those movies came from
yeah because I'm curious to see how well
it translates to other cultures yeah 80s
American stuff translates extremely well
yep
and it's kind of like a um across the
board like I said it's a lot of like 80s
Classics like they watch Predator and
alien and Aliens the thing yeah The
Exorcist yeah
um the thing well that breaks them out
it did yeah they had a hard time
grasping the thing in a certain way they
thought it was kind of like possession
it's in him they keep saying it's in him
no yeah it's not in him that's that's
the thing it's like yeah it's an
imitation of yeah yeah but I mean you
know they still got the gist but I think
they didn't really I think the only
thing because we watched last night or
the night before we watched them
reacting to Shrek the original one and I
said I think the only thing like they
thought it was hilarious and they loved
donkey but um I think they didn't
because they don't have the same fairy
tales over there like so they didn't
really get like why suddenly these three
blind mice are running around or Snow
White is like on the table dead broad
off of the table you know what I mean
like they didn't get why like all of
that was happening like the Pinocchio
thing and all that because they don't
have those fairy tales where they don't
have the same and I don't think they
understood like that the that it was
kind of making fun of Disney a little
bit like with the way the castle was and
like Shrek coming in with the you know
through the um the little gate thing and
all that so I think they didn't really
get that but they still thought it was
like super funny but like I said they
didn't have the same context as but I
was actually really surprised how
um they were really into they loved Back
to the Future they loved all the horror
movies and [__] like that and I like the
thing I like about those two guys is
that they are
they're like just completely
um guileless they're just completely
like immersed they become completely
immersed in the story you know what I
mean like if it's sad they're just like
they'll cry you know it's like you know
what I mean they cried at the end of
train to Busan and I was like I feel
like I cried at the end of trying to
boost on too but um middle easterners
are kind of misunderstood
in the west
um
I've been to Egypt and
all my uncles and aunts and
were uh basically grew up
in Isfahan Iran before the Revolution of
the Ayatollah command
my grandfather worked for at that time
Grumman
Grumman Aerospace and he was there
training the Shah of Iran's men how to
build an airplane that or excuse me how
to maintain an airplane that he that he
helped build it was called the F-14
Tomcat
my granddad did all the
fuel injection systems and all the
programming that they did which is back
in those days man it was like I think it
was tree [__] chip I think a lot of
his transistors and [__] but how to uh
fuel inject that day and he took all my
his daughters with him my aunts and to
this day a lot of my aunts and uncles
are still pretty heavily tied in
to the Middle East you know UAE and
[__] Dubai
two of my uncles are bodyguards and
Shopper Pilots for [__] real Rich
guys in [__] Dubai
their late 50s [__] jacked and [__]
um when I was at I used to hang out with
him when I was at [__] Fort Campbell
they were from task force 160 Special
Operations Aviation
they were the chopper Pilots for [__]
Delta Delta Force basically they flew
other people too but they called them
customers
but those guys are all
flying for Middle Eastern shakes now
[__] concealed full auto [__] pdws
and [__]
and uh you know they made hundreds of
hundreds of thousands of years just
living down there being Chopper pilot
bodyguard
well
when I went there man in Egypt I kind of
this is in the 90s when I first went
there
I really didn't know didn't know didn't
know what to expect what impressed me
about Egyptians and just middle
easterners and Muslims in general when
they're in their own environment is how
sweet they are they're very sweet
dispositioned people they have all this
you because of [__] all this Islamic
terrorism you know which I think was
kind of blown into something that really
wasn't that did exist but there wasn't
that many of them I don't think
it kind of come across as being these
[__] real mean big [__] cruel
dudes they're a small framed dudes and
they're
very
gentle
in general
um
you could sit around and [__] a drink
crocodile with them and [__] talk
about they love religion and and
mythicism and mythology so you you have
to [__] deal with them on their own
cultural level you have to understand
Islam yeah I mean that's kind of true
everyone with everything yeah
and uh whenever you go to a foreign land
you want to adhere to their cultural
norms yeah and they have a lot of
misconceptions about westerners too
especially Western women they have a lot
of misconceptions about that
um
some of it's right but blown out of
proportion
um but
all in all they're very much like like
dealing with say like a a devout Mormon
or a devout Christian it's it's the same
religion basically it's just Islam is a
like the second chapter of Christianity
it's got Jesus in it it's got
rebooted stories from the new testament
old testament
so to kind of establish a common
understanding
I would always start talking about Islam
and [__] distort their stories about
you know like babadra which is like
uh Sodom and Gomorrah you know we talk
about the differences in them and we
talk about the cultural differences
about religious law and they love that
[__] okay
Muslims love [__] religion
even if it's not their own but if as
long as it's as long as it's a um what
do you call it
God of Abraham you start talking about
old Old Testament figures abrahamic they
love all that
John Smith said my family is Albanian
we're known as the politest people in
the world before they shoot you really
well also very polite because everyone
has about 50 cousins who may take
offense yeah yeah I see that one
Southern I did well in the Middle East
because it's they're not a legalistic
society it's very much like the South
they're they're an honor based society
if you make a friend there he's really
your friend he'll break a law for you
there's all kinds of weird Traditions
like you know if you're in trouble you
run into a man's house he's your friend
and he protects you there's like a spell
of protection nobody can come in there
now if you leave they'll NAB you but
there's just a lot of traditions the a
lot of Islamic Traditions that you know
are very um honorable they're very
they're honorable
and they're not all the same each
country has a different you can't lump
them all together
big difference between say Saudi Arabia
modern Saudi Arabia and Afghanistan it's
just
it's a different ethnic group different
culture everything
well like I said the I it's interesting
because
particularly these
um you know reacting to movies channels
because you subscribe to two of them and
the one that I like that's the two guys
from Pakistan
they seem more like they're more modern
they had seen other movies they'd never
seen western movies before before this
person that made the channel you're
watching my body but they had seen
Bollywood movies and stuff like that so
and you know and [__] like that however
there is another one and I can't
remember what it's called it's usually
like three guys and those guys at least
the old guy because they have one it's
like two younger guys and one like
really old man
and um that old guy when he saw
um I guess it was Back to the Future
right yeah yeah it was Back to the
Future they loved Back to the Future but
he said that it's like oh you guys had
phones and cars and [__] like that like
in the 80s they didn't have that and
they didn't have that like where they
were from so they were from some little
tiny like Backwater somewhere yeah well
that's why it was called the developing
world right it used to be
you know grew up in Brazil and Brazil
was a developing country but it wasn't
that far behind
the United States it was behind the
United States because it was it had
enclosed borders and they wouldn't let
you import
foreign technology because they're
oligarchs that ran the country didn't
want foreign composition that's really
all it was
and I went to school with the children
of those oligarchs
at a private school called Escola de Sao
Paulo [__] one of the best schools in
South America High School
so um
yeah developing nations were developing
back in the 80s a lot of them were
[__] up yeah but that's not the
situation anymore today no
um
you have all these people spilling
across the border and you have people
here in the United States that have no
understanding of geography or foreign
countries or foreign
you know kind of like they're running
from Hell or something no those
countries are [__] paradises
[__] great food the economies may not
be good Venezuela has political problems
right now
but really [__] me and Jenny could
move to say Mexico we could go to Brazil
I wouldn't go to Brazil right now my
friends that I grew up with in Brazil
say don't go right now
it's kind of like the way Columbia used
to be back in the 80s but you could go
to Mexico Colombia
um [__] Argentina's getting good
getting back on track I loved Chile when
I was there I liked Uruguay and Paraguay
I mean a lot of people go there on
vacation those places are [__]
gorgeous right just you don't hear much
about them it's on the other side it's
on the it's in it's in the southern
equator yeah and they're kind of in
their own little world but they're
beautiful places super friendly people
uh developed
um great food and a long history and me
and Jenny could go to Brazil Argentina
Paraguay Uruguay Chile and fit in
you're like whoa you guys you guys are
white man if this is filled with white
people I feel a [__] white people
yeah it's got Japanese people in it yeah
Brazil has one of the largest Japanese
they're yeah it's a lot more diverse
there's a lot of people that don't
[__] know what they're talking about
and uh
you know you're gonna go to Brazil
you're gonna see a lot of white people
you won't even see that many black
people not like black people from Africa
you'll see a bunch of mixed people but
you won't see that many black people
because all the black people married
white people yeah you know that's what
happened there thank you very much Jeffy
aren't homesick so I can't work at the
club major upside I get to hang out with
you guys tonight oh that's nice yeah
Victor says Columbia looks cool Chile
has always been on my bucket list
Julia's great I have the best
earthquakes and I've always had a thing
for earthquakes yeah Tom's been yeah
went to Santiago for like a week and a
half I [__] loved it was a teenager I
would actually like to go to Chile that
was great beautiful women just every
good looking people yeah real good
looking people yeah they got uh Indians
and then they have more European style
people
um and they're just they're just good
looking people uh although people people
kind of underestimate how good-looking
South Americans are Colombia has some of
the best looking people
they have their own look but they have
some of the best looking people in South
America they don't look like our
argentines
people from Argentina look more European
they look more European in Argentina
than they do even in Brazil
but you just got to go to the regions to
get a feel for them and you make friends
down there and
what always impressed me was great
weather
and uh
beautiful
natural resources uh beautiful forests
planes uh mountains beautiful beaches
and fantastic food
unimaginable food the beef is [__]
great
pork chicken fruits that you've never
seen before like fructose which is I
don't know what the net is looks like a
dab green hand grenade you open it up
it's a bunch of paste white paste and
it's kind of like if you were to it's
got seeds in it big seeds
it's kind of like you were to take
banana and apple and puree it together
oh I've heard of that yeah [__]
really good yeah
um
mango papaya
something called matakuja which is I
think in English it's called passion
fruit
um just and then stuff you never see
like
massage which means Rose Apple it's a
little bitty apple and you bite it and
it tastes like an apple flavored with
roses not that big really good
little tiny bananas that are only like
that big that are orange in color and
they taste like apples
yeah
all kinds of wild [__] man
and uh
if you're a passport bro they got dudes
that are trying I was I was the original
passport bro I was on a passport when I
was a teenager because my parents took
me so I wasn't like
I was an unwilling passport bro
s were [__] Off the Chain man because
uh if you look good and you're a
foreigner you're gonna you do well there
and you just make friends and just
don't go down there to be snaking all
the women you go down there to just make
friends make friends with dudes yeah
just like hang out just like a yeah well
I mean I feel like that's true and yeah
there you go you make friends with dudes
that are into the same [__] that you're
in you make friends with dudes and then
all of a sudden you're making friends
with women and and you're in your own
Social Circle
and um
you don't want to go down there like the
Ugly American or even ugly European
where you're acting like you're Superior
to them no their their shit's wired
tight okay they know their area they're
very intelligent and educated people so
you don't want to go down there with a
holier than thou mentality with them
yeah your your money goes a little
further
because of exchange rates that is that
doesn't improve you as a person though
no you know yeah and I kind of feel like
probably 99 of the problem that a lot of
people have with Americans coming to
their country is because of that like
yeah and and that's a stereotype for a
reason and I'm not saying that it's like
a lot of Americans do go to other
countries and are totally nice and they
blend in and everything like that but
it's like there is a certain type of
person well that goes overseas and
they're just like they want everything
to be like and so I've noticed some
British people are like this I was going
to say that they want everything to be
like like it was back home and they get
really upset when it's not and it's just
kind of like you know British didn't
didn't do well in Brazil they went to a
British school it was called Saint
Mary's Academy it was like a uh I think
it was just Catholic private Academy
because he had British expats doing
business in Brazil
some of them had been there for decades
they've kind of lived on little
compounds and only hung out with other
British people they didn't mingle with
Brazilians at all kind of like they were
dealing with a foreign alien race or
something yeah crazy crazy and they
wouldn't learn Portuguese they would
just
you know they didn't even bother to
learn Portuguese but they never was it
was weird with the British in Brazil is
that you know the kids that had hung up
the British kids that I hung out with
who were expats most of them never
really experienced Brazil
now the guys that I hung out with did
but they would tell me about the other
kids at their school right you know what
I mean no [__] his name was Tom Riley
and his little brother's name was a
I forgot what I think it might have been
rich
and uh
you know he'd run around with me and the
other Brazilian guys in high school
drink beer and he chased Brazilian girls
and [__] but he was normal
his parents weren't though they were
like cloistered yeah and all his friends
would just [__] stay on their little
compounds
I noticed that miniature little
miniature England yeah when I was in the
UK and like you said it was a
generational thing because like people
my age and younger
um were a lot more open they'd go all
over the world and like they would just
blend in and they didn't they weren't
weird about it but the older ones it's
like let's go to Greece for holidays but
they stay like on a British compound
yeah it's ridiculous it's like that has
like little trailers like what we would
call trailers
and you know has a little Pub there and
everybody speaks English and stuff like
that I'm like yeah why you just stay
home
the only group that was worse than that
were the Japanese because in that school
that I went to that high school I went
to it had Japanese girls very few
Japanese boys think we had two
it's because the boys would stay in
Japan to get a real education the girls
education didn't matter so much they
could go to an international [__] IB
International Baccalaureate school they
were [__] crazy but they were there
working for I think Toyota
uh
and uh the Japanese girls never learned
Portuguese
learned a little bit of English they
could read and write English they could
understand it but they wouldn't barely
speak it
and uh they just stayed cloistered
their whole family we have to stay in
their apartments and then go to work and
then come in they had drivers that would
drive them right in front of work
because they weren't really trusted
behind the wheel in Brazilian traffic
well I wouldn't drive in Brazil either
yeah so they wouldn't go out to
restaurants or anything they ate
Japanese food at home and tried to
assemble Japanese type food they were
scared to death to go out because they
thought they'd get robbed that's
according to like I talked to the girls
in Portuguese class there was one
sitting right next to me I've got the
whole Lowdown that her dad was afraid to
go anywhere so they just stayed up yeah
and I was like what are you why is it
because you get robbed why you know
because look at us it's because you're
Japanese like yeah it says Nah
Brazilians aren't going to do that
because yeah they're gonna rob you
they're good people they're scared of
them though yeah now it was just was
Brazil dangerous yeah yes it was
dangerous yeah
but you could avoid all trouble
I knew where to get in trouble and where
to avoid it it's the same thing you know
you'd only get robbed in certain parts
of town and it you know
and only if you [__] we're kind of
showing weakness calling for it then
that would happen I never got robbed
actually I take that back
a guy tried to rob me and I said [__]
put that [__] gun away man you want
money I'm a foreigner here I was
speaking Portuguese and this is I know I
know shit's rough how much you want I'll
just give you some money
and I just I gave about half of what I
had which was about 20 bucks and he
thanked me and walked off
all he wanted was funny he just wanted
some money right he pulled a gun on me
and everything I said put that [__]
thing away
he was only a few years ago
you know it was in a narco tyranny Jenny
said that I thrive in a narco tyranny
yeah yeah you love that kind of I love
it
an anarcho tyranny the government was a
charity
it made all kinds of its purpose was not
to help the people just to tax them and
Define them
the police just find you and give you
give you tickets that's all it did they
didn't help you if you were in trouble
they'd run the other way if there was a
gunfight
so there were no real police really
and the government was just there to
grift and to cover its own ass over all
the stealing that they were doing it was
just another animal in the jungle it was
just another faction
then there were gangs and cartels and
just regular people and
there were laws but you could you didn't
have to follow them nobody else followed
them
and if you got in trouble you could buy
your way out of any trouble
even murder if you were if you were if
you were Rich yeah well I think that's
kind of true yeah
not just Brazil and if it was kind of
understandable if it was a Serial
Killing Type no well yeah but if you
killed a guy in a fight
right he was trying to kill you so you
killed him yeah you could buy your way
out of that yeah
yeah especially if he was poor
well like I said you could probably do
that here too yeah now if he was rich
you'd have to you'd have to buy that
other family off right
um
so I come from I come from a background
of not respected laws because they were
just made by [__] criminals really
you went by a code of honor your own
personal ethics your own how you treat
other people everything's face to face
like a Native American really
like a Native American tribesman the
[__] the governments were kind of
parasitic they were just there to take
you kind of start seeing that now here
in the U.S it's just a parasitic entity
it's just here to take
it's not really here for you it's going
to export all your jobs away and then
import more [__] cheap labor to just
crush the labor market
because they want a country of surfs
with no rights
and who's doing it is corporations
the corporations that own the political
parties
everybody knows everybody's got half a
cent half a brain and this isn't new
it's been like this yeah it's been like
this it's just that now that the
internet is exposing it
John Smith said as William Burroughs
said along the lines of Americans go to
the other side of the world only to
speak to other Americans about not being
able to buy a hamburger yeah yeah and
the same is true of Brits but they're
like why can't we get any good chips in
this [__] place but yeah I gotta just
I just gotta disagree
but there are some like that so all the
American families that I went to school
with in Brazil that they all lived in
Brazil
they weren't like that they were
enjoying Brazil yeah and they were
learning Portuguese and all the all the
high school guys and girls that I grew
up with in Brazil that were American all
spoke Portuguese you can learn it in
about a year
uh when you're young it's easy to learn
you would get private tutors and [__]
well that's what you had that right yeah
and he and he still speaks it you still
speak it yeah I dream in it if I dream
about yeah and I my vocabulary in my
dreams is much better because my
subconscious remembers so much stuff I
haven't really spoken in a conversation
in a long time it's funny because every
now and then I don't want to hear it
like a year or two ago like you used to
correspond with a dude that was in
Brazil like about motorcycles yeah and
so every now and then I'd hear him like
in the other room like speaking like
really rapid fire Portuguese like this
other guy like and I was just like [__]
man you can still like [__] yeah you
can do it when you're not thinking about
it yeah
yeah but he like yeah he's still like uh
fairly fluent I would I would say like
my first girlfriends were Brazilians
yeah
um so that was a big [__] motivation
to speak Portuguese
you know what I mean I mean if I was
living in another country I would
absolutely either try to learn the
language beforehand or learn it while I
was there because why wouldn't you yeah
I'm not gonna live in another country
and like not
be able to communicate with anybody that
just seems like counterproductive yeah
um yeah Ben says look up those supposed
list of complaint letters to tour
operators about how no one could speak
English the food was all foreign
those are people that do not live yeah I
mean this those are just there are
definitely but here's the thing I always
thought to myself like look if you're
gonna spend all that money to go to
another country
why on Earth would you expect it to be I
mean if you want if you want [__] that
you can get back home just stay home
it's much cheaper I mean the whole point
of going to another country is to
experience the other country like
experience another culture like if you
just want the same [__] you can get at
home then just stay at home Zach said I
said something's the most badass thing
he's heard I don't know what it is the
the thing where the guy like pulled the
gun on you oh yeah and you just gave him
money God's never impressed me I grew up
shooting them you know and then I made a
living with them in the Army and as a
contractor it
guns don't mean anything to me
this house is filled with them
well and I think you and particularly
nowadays I don't know about back then
because I didn't know you then but I do
kind of feel like nowadays you do kind
of have a thing where you don't really
I'm not saying you have a death wish but
you don't really care no I'm indifferent
he's indifferent that's whether he lives
or does you know what I mean yeah well
I kind of developed what
what Musashi was talking about says that
you have no right as a warrior Warrior
to take the life of anyone into you
yourself are willing to
except death when it's handed out to you
without a single complaint
that's a great [__] thing yeah that's
it he knows what he's talking about that
dude went through with some [__] and he
killed over 100 people
the
you have no right to kill anyone until
unless
you can accept your own death when it's
handed out to you without any complaint
which is that's
Kamikaze mentality but that's just the
way infantry and stuff were from the era
that me and bees nest what they did to
us in the history were just like that
but it kind of got I was like that from
South America too because they're kind
of like that
there's some [__]
toxoplasmosis [__] let me go
the restroom
Jeffy Hart said when I traveled to China
for work I pleaded with my Chinese
co-workers to eat where the locals ate
some of the best experiences in my
travels were all around local Cuisine
amazing times yeah see it's like I don't
want to [__] I don't want to go to
another country and eat a [__]
McDonald's or KFC man I can do that here
but you know I wanna I wanna eat with it
I want to eat with Dave I want to hang
out ready to hang out like I do I you
know I do want to see the touristy
tourist [__] too
but I don't really want to spend a lot
of time doing that you know what I mean
like when I was in the UK yeah I went to
the touristy [__] I went and saw the
Tower of London and I saw all of that
kind of stuff and I went to all the
museums and everything but because I was
living there I also kind of did just
regular people [__] you know what I mean
so it was a lot more
I don't know it was just like a lot
better experience because it wasn't we
weren't just doing like touristy [__]
all the time
um yeah Ben says Ed anger of the weekly
world news yeah that like fake column
that used to have in there wrote a
column once about how holidays overseas
were a scam and he preferred to take his
wife to Disney World where he could
visit dozens of other countries yeah
that's not actually Disney World that's
actually Epcot actually I'm going to
Epcot I think on Wednesday like the day
after my birthday because my brother uh
works for the Disney parks he's one of
the guys that you know when you go to
the Disney parks and you know uh and
you're like hey I want my kids picture
taken with you know Moana or Tigger or
whoever
um my brother takes the pictures of the
family and then you know what I mean so
he does that and um so he can get
several people into the Disney parks for
free so he wants to go to Epcot on
Wednesday we're going to the Halloween
uh Disney thing on Tuesday night we made
my sister went last year and it was
super fun so we're gonna do that again
this year and both my brothers are going
too and then we're gonna go to Epcot on
Wednesday but yeah you can go well the
whole reason that people like Epcot is
because of the world showcase because
see in Disney I don't think in the
Disney parks you can't get booze Epcot
you can get booze and you can go all
around the world you can go to Germany
you can go to all of a sudden and get
all the good booze so that's what people
do
in Florida that's what they that's what
they call it drinking around the world
you go to the world showcase and drink
it every single country
like get all the like booze but yeah
that's the whole thing that people do
here
because people are like well some of the
Disney parks don't have alcohol but
Epcot does so everybody gets some tricks
that all in all the different country
bars but it's uh yeah I've been up kind
of in a really long time
it's funny because I went to Epcot when
they first opened it I think I went in
1985. I want to say it opened in 1985.
and I was in
fifth grade and our class went on a
field trip
and it was super fun but it's changed a
lot since then I've been once since then
but that was probably
15 20 years ago maybe more actually
maybe more now that I'm thinking about
it maybe 20 years ago but I haven't been
since then so I don't know what they I
don't know what they have there
so we'll see we'll see because we're
gonna go we'll probably just me and my
brother will probably just get really
drunk
that's probably what'll happen but oh
well it's my birthday I'm gonna have a
good day
um yeah post says just stick to the
teacup right it's that way the puke
stick the puke stays food what okay yeah
maybe
um yeah Mickey Mouse mug shots yeah
that's what that's what he does he walks
around the park and takes pictures of
people and then they sell the pictures
but uh he works at different Parks I
mean it's not always Disney it's Animal
Kingdom it's Epcot it's Hollywood
Studios which used to be MGM
what is she doing
Ben says what does it stand for
experimental city of tomorrow yeah I
think it's something like that wasn't it
experimental prototype I think it was
Prototype city of tomorrow or something
yeah it's what's funny is just how lame
but how lame Disney is
you had the damn land of tomorrow that
future world had all the damn head to
Monsanto ride where you they shrunk you
down I don't think they have that
anymore there was a Disney that was it
no that well yeah they had that at Epcot
here I went on it once but that was a
long time ago then they had the [__]
these weird rocket rides and then they
had this [__] people mover they would
[__] take you on the cable cars
and it's like they were going on about
how futuristic the [__] was but you'd
look at that you go man this thing
futuristic this is 1962. but see that's
what I kind of like about it because I
kind of like pictures that retro
futurism yeah that's why I like all
those like old shorts that they show on
MST and stuff because they're like look
at all those futuristic [__] it's like
obviously it's not but um I don't know
there's something about that aesthetic
that I like yeah but they used to have a
bunch of like displays there
they're they're long gone I mean they
were gone even when I was a little kid
where it would show like the home of
tomorrow yeah and walk through it and
it's got ovens and dishwashers and yeah
it's wait it'd be Retro by today's
standards but by those standards back
then that was kind of I just I think
it's cool because no microwaves yeah I
think it's cool because it's kind of
like a time capsule and it's like and I
like the idea of like this optimism it's
like oh we're gonna have all this cool
[__] like in the future and it's like
even if it didn't quite work out like
that
um you know what I mean and now it looks
like a little
you know it looks a little cheesy but
it's like I still kind of like that
though like last time when me and my
sister went to um take some out of
Fallout went to Disney last year
um we did we did all that [__] we went
on like everything we went on uh we went
on um what is it uh what the [__] it's a
small world we did that we went on the
Carousel of Progress like with it where
they show like the house you know from a
long time ago it's like here's the house
during the Great Depression and here was
that like we did all that we just like
and it's I don't know it's like super
fun I like that kind of [__] well all
that [__] was real
um important in the 60s because yeah
World War II it just ended
it's so funny uh
conservatives all right
they had this weird concept about
trying to about American traditions and
wanting to go back to the nuclear family
and you know well which I'm not saying
it's a bad thing but wanting to go back
to what was shown in the 50s and the 60s
as if that was the default setting for
the United States it wasn't no that was
actually totally artificial
Hollywood
the army
and the intelligence agencies all just
kind of [__] ganged up together
to try to keep all these [__] Ultra
dangerous [__] World War II veterans
in line they had to [__] control them
somehow and the best way to control them
is to give them jobs in Auto factories
and factories and you know gotta settle
right and to get them married and to get
them into a new thing called a Suburban
home those didn't exist before
and it worked and they did it with the
aid of Hollywood they made all the
television shows like you know [__]
father's knows best Leave it to Beaver I
Dream of Genie uh Bewitched yeah that
was like that was like the idea like
yeah you were supposed to inspire it was
all propaganda to do that which is very
smart
and they thought it was going to look
like what they showed in Disneyland
tomorrow or future
it didn't work out that way because the
guys that were running that program got
old and died and things moved on and
they wanted to make profit and the best
best way to make profit was to export
all those [__] jobs over to China
which that didn't work out that's not
gonna and then try to turn this into a
service economy and that didn't work out
either
those jobs have to come back okay
because China's not on the same page
with us
they're our enemy basically they don't
like us
uh so we're gonna have to make all that
[__] here because once you have an enemy
making all your stuff
your your
um they have you on over a barrel
basically
because they can withhold product
or they could sabotage product like sell
you computers and all the chips
have something in there for back doors
so they can go into them
and spy on you and weird [__] like that
Warfare is not like what it was it's
fifth generational now it's run by
psychologists
and
people that [__] with the Mind goes all
the way back to [__] MK Ultra
that's what Mk Ultra is all about
Warfare has to do with the Mind anyway a
person surrenders when they believe that
they're defeated
because they don't believe their
defeated they'll just continue to fight
so controlling the mind is a [__]
very powerful tool
Camp guy says no matter what anybody
says Disney parks are incredible I
couldn't even tell you which one was my
favorite between Magic Kingdom Epcot and
the animal kingdom MGM Grand part great
too yeah I actually haven't I haven't
been to the park it's called Hollywood
Studios now I think
um I haven't been to it since it was MGM
but that honestly the Tower of Terror is
worth it just for that but they have a
lot of other cool [__] my sister goes
all the time because she has a um an
annual pass she lives in Atlanta so she
comes down a few times a year and goes
all that and she loves all that [__] so
she's been to all of them like she'll
come down for a week and then she just
hops from park to park but I haven't
been to like I I just went to Disney
like Magic Kingdom last year because me
and her went for the Halloween event
and they've got like lots of new [__]
there and we were checking that out I
wanna um specifically go on the neutron
thing because they were building it last
year that's Disney yeah yeah they were
building it it's by the like the Grand
Prix Raceway yeah yeah they built a Tron
ride now my sister's been on it but
because she's been since then but it's
like they were still working on it when
I was there last year so I didn't get to
go on it look Disney I've been to Disney
and the other Park recently
and Disney's looking very dated compared
to Universal Universal when we last we
went there how long ago was that that
was a long time ago that was when we
were still hanging out with mini me yeah
because mini me was about eight years
probably
maybe more yeah maybe ten yeah maybe 10.
still [__] Epcot was [__] way
ahead of uh excuse me Universal
Universal was way ahead of Disney and I
heard Disney's kind of gotten shabbier
looking it wasn't bad when I was there
last year it was actually looked like it
was pretty [__] and span but you know
okay and like I said last time I went
that was more than 10 years ago well
that was a long time ago they've added a
bunch they've added a bunch of new [__]
they've added a bunch of new [__] and
and like I said we me and my sister had
a [__] blast at the Halloween thing
last year if Disney's gonna survive It's
gotta [__] rebuild those Parks it's
gonna it's gonna make them at least on
par with what what Universal has
Universal's [__] super high tech yeah
that [__] Harry Potter broomstick
ride it was like a virtual reality ride
just sitting on those rooms
I bought into it man I felt like I was
[__] riding on a bruise he loved that
Harry Potter I felt like I felt like I
was on a [__] roller coaster they're
just sitting on a fake thing and going
through the damn tracks and they're
blowing wind on you and big [__]
screens everywhere but it it felt like
you were flying on a broomstick it's a
trip man well the thing about yeah I
mean they built the entire and um they
built Hogwarts and they built like the
whole um what is it called Diagon Alley
or whatever it's called they built all
that [__] and I was just like well I
admire their commitment to the [__]
theming that was a cool ride yeah if you
were offering me a choice today which
one to go to I'd say [__] Universal
yeah I mean if you're more into like
thrill rides and [__] like that yeah
Universal is what you want to do because
that has like a lot more roller coasters
and [__] like that like Disney's got a
couple
um you know they're pretty good but
you know it's more that well Disney is
more geared toward like younger like
kids which universals more towards
adults yeah they got a hot [__]
superheroes walking around
you know [__] spandex of [__] that's
where all the hotties are and and it's
it's it's fun it's it's a real fun park
it's real high tech and it it just looks
good
it's very you know the paint's fresh and
big sculptures and [__]
it always freaks me out because like I
said my my brother
works at the Disney parks and he said
you would not believe because he knows
he knows where all the secret [__] is
like where all the secret break rooms
are for the employees and where he's
like when I first started working there
is like and they were giving us a tour
of everything and he's like they they
they showed me this one place and he's
like this blew my [__] mind he's like
it was this gigantic
warehouse and it had every single
costume and uniform in like millions of
different sizes like and he's like and
I'm not just talking about like the
character costumes and [__] like that
but he's like I'm talking about the
uniforms of like you know the people on
the Safari ride or the people in every
single Park and he's just like it's just
racks and racks and racks and it's like
three floors and he's like and it's
[__] massive it looks like an
airplane Hangar and he's just like and
he's like even the people that work in
like the restaurants that have the
uniforms it's like they just have
millions of different sizes like of
every single thing and he's just like I
couldn't [__] believe it and he told
me he's like they even have their own
paint mixing Warehouse like facility and
he's like if you work there you can
actually get paint for super cheap and
they will match absolutely any you just
bring them a little chip of something
and they will match it they can make any
single any color in the universe they
can make it and you get it for like
super super cheap if you're an employee
there and he's like that is something
that I never thought that I would
he's like I never thought that would be
a benefit but he's like that's pretty
[__] cool so he thought that was
pretty cool but he's like they just have
their own because they have to keep
everything painted and all this other
kind of [__] so they have their own
paint mixing
facility like in the Parks he's like
there's like a million million things
that you don't see back there but it's
like it was just funny like him telling
me all that
but yeah so he's gonna he's gonna
come with us on
because like I said I was like the
Halloween thing because they do
um
like I said Disney is more kid oriented
so they do a Halloween event starting in
September it's usually like for two
months because you know obviously
Universal does Halloween Horror Nights
and that's like super super scary
because it's more like geared toward
adults I haven't been in a long time but
the one I went to it's like pretty scary
so you know the the Disney one is more
geared toward kids so it's like scary
but it's not that scary like because
they don't want to like scare the crap
out of little kids or anything like that
but um but they do some cool [__] like
they did and they're probably doing it
again this year but they did a thing
where you know uh Space Mountain like
you ride Space Mountain but they turn
all the lights off so it's like
completely black and you can't see
anything
um they do that they have like the
Haunted Mansion they have like all these
live actors like inside the Mansion like
[__] with you and stuff like that
kind of like a house at Universal they
had like [__] like that and they do a
big show
um where they put like all these
projections like on the castle and it's
like they have all these [__] they
have the um you know uh the Sanderson
sisters from Hocus Pocus and Oogie
Boogie and they have all that kind of
stuff and it's like this big spectacular
and fireworks and a big parade and [__]
but uh yeah it was like super fun last
year and they give you as much
free candy as you want
which is probably not good but they have
these big huge they have big barrels of
like candy and they give you a bag at
the beginning of the night and you just
go around and anytime you see a barrel
you can be like hey and they'll put up
like a whole bunch of candy in there so
you can have like unlimited candy it's
like pretty awesome
pretty awesome
but yeah we had a really good time so
I'm really looking forward to it I'm
looking forward to it because we went
last year and like I said I haven't been
to Epcot for a long time either so that
might be kind of fun I don't even know
what's there anymore
I don't remember the the last time I
went
was with my parents so that was probably
that had to be maybe maybe even 30 years
ago now that I'm thinking about it yikes
it was a long time ago
oh yeah Julie Newmar yeah I remember her
um
Zach says speaking of MGM their Casino
in Vegas is being held hostage by a
hacker group at the moment none of their
machines are working I hadn't heard
about that I heard I hadn't heard about
that
it's pretty funny
yeah Jeffy Hart said The Not So Scary
Halloween is the event yeah yeah that's
what it's called
my nieces and nephews used to go there
all the time the Sugar Rush drove my
sister and mom crazy yeah because like I
said
they will just give you as much candy as
you want it's like unlimited candy
aside from all the other things that you
can buy because they have because every
single restaurant and everything like
that has like a bunch of special like
Halloween desserts or Halloween Foods or
something like that but then they also
have all the free candy that you go
around and get to so there's also that
uh James home says my mom moved to
Kissimmee recently she's already
complaining about the heat it's right up
here yeah that's that's where Disney is
yeah
um that's what I'm saying if you've
never been to Florida it's kind of hard
to adequately convey it's hotter than
Mississippi how hot it is because it's
100 humidity so just [__] you up like I
was born here cooling off now yeah it's
not bad like in the morning and at night
it's still hot but it's not
that bad but it's like I was born here
and it's like even now like I'll walk
out the door and be like are you [__]
kidding me yeah I still do that
and you'd think I'd be used to it you
never get used to it
American traditions are European
tradition that's not the Traditions that
we're talking about
we're talking about the cultural
expectations of a middle class lifestyle
and what the middle class lifestyle
looked like
when I was a kid
what the American middle class lifestyle
was supposed to look and feel like it
was is very well depicted in
in Steven Spielberg movies
yeah like uh Close Encounters the Third
Kind
um Poltergeist Poltergeist
you live in a
in like a two-story house
it's real modern
it's in a [__] a pre-planned
community
you have a job with some kind of factory
or some kind of a utility or
something you have a wife who's in you
know her early 30s
you got kids two or three of them boys
and girls and they're going to a local
school here they got skateboards and
bicycles and [__] and there's kids on
all the blocks
foreign
that tone that they were trying to show
that Spielberg [__] nailed it he was
really good he'd be a really good
propagandist that may have been American
propaganda
but it kind of came true that's the way
things were for a while and that's
it's still kind of like that for some
people but not as many as it was because
the the middle class is just
the rich people are just sucking all the
money out of the [__] middle class
there's only going to be you know the
top one percent and everybody else is
going to be [__] real poor eventually
if we don't stop it they got the money
pump on they're [__] sending all the
money away from us to them
they're doing it by exporting [__]
jobs
and crushing labor markets and prevent
preventing the formation of unions
things like that
things that Democrats used to be about
but they got bought off they don't want
anything about [__] unions now
that's why you know if you think in
these political parties you think the
Republicans and the Democrats are going
to [__] save you you're [__]
tripping
all right they work for Wayland
Industries
sad but true
and uh the situation in Europe it'll
never be like it was in the 80s here in
the United States
not in the Spielberg version of the way
life is supposed to be that's the way I
thought life was going to be
didn't turn out that way for me
house looks the same everything else is
different
I didn't know I'd be working on stream
mate
jerking horny [__]
the camera I didn't think about it
either but you know you got to do what
you gotta do
I don't honestly I don't mind it it's
more fun than doing some other [__] I'd
rather do that it's amazing than work at
a restaurant or something you know and
not everybody's like that like some
people would rather do anything other
than that but you know
it's not
yeah they work for Specter exactly
that's exactly yeah they work for
specter
gangs of Rich oligarchs
who are [__] crazy
you want to get rid of us so they can
inherit the world
live in the Garden of Eden they're
tripping though they're like any other
Nazi or commie or anything like that
they think that they think that they can
cause chaos and then just survive it
once chaos happens man they lose control
they'll be the first well that's what
they don't seem to understand is that
like eventually eventually it's gonna be
there um that's gonna come back and
invite you in the end they're gonna
create a tiger and they think they can
run there's more of us than there are
yeah
yeah anything is is that we're in the
modern world now we know where they all
live
exactly okay
all right do they talk about a civil war
you could never defeat the United States
Army man I was [__] born and raised
from an early age in military academies
to be in that U.S army that U.S the US
Army ain't [__] anymore
okay they couldn't even handle the
[__] Taliban and that was just a few
75 IQ dudes and flip-flops with old AKs
you win Wars by out enduring people
all these expensive Jets and tanks that
don't mean nothing because they could
never bring those to bear on you it's
just constant resistance same way we
beat the British
they never [__] won any major battles
against the British
we just kept saying no to them we were
just stubborn no no no no no not doing
it
eventually they [__] people they just
got sick of us yeah they just gave up
they whipped our ass and left they
whipped our ass in the War of 1812
burned down the [__] white house and
[__] look at Dolly Madison and James
Madison ran and everything and then they
left they said okay that's it [__] it I
[__] your [__] up we're sick of you
we're leaving we're not coming well it
like wasn't worth it to them anymore it
wasn't worth it to them anymore because
we were just like too much they kicked
their ass until they just got sick of it
and left
endurance wins Wars not all this
technology the Pentagon just came out
with a report a few weeks ago saying the
[__] culture trumps all strategy and
Technology that's how they were
explaining what happened in Afghanistan
and Iraq
you don't need technology you just need
a real strong culture
and the [__]
the afghanis and the Iraqis Islam proved
that their culture is stronger than ours
it just has a [__] unlimited
endurance
you can just whip on them and blow up
[__] wedding [__] parties and
[__] do [__] for [__] decades it
doesn't change them it makes them
[__] hate you more
well yeah it just makes them more like
you know nobody's gonna dig their heels
well that's what your friends over here
to [__] kill them they didn't do
anything wrong that's what me and that's
what most people would do yeah you know
so that's what most people would do I
don't I don't understand why they think
that they would react any different
push these buttons and pull these
triggers are weak old men that have
never been even in a fist fight they're
just trying to they're projecting their
own weakness onto other people because
they live in a life of luxury they have
a lot of money and well if somebody did
this to me I'd quit yeah because you're
weak you know you haven't been toughened
up by life you know
well I mean the thing about it too is
that you're attacking their I mean
that's their family that's their life
that's their livelihood they don't have
anywhere else to go you know what I mean
what do you expect to happen yeah
they're gonna fight you to the last
[__] breath yeah because like they
don't have anything else to do they
don't have any other options well they
take it personally
right and that's what I'm saying what is
personal they did yeah they take it
personally it's of course the dudes that
make these decisions in the ruling class
don't take it personally they don't
because it's never going to affect them
right it doesn't affect you that's what
we will do this and they have other
options they're like oh well [__] that
I'll just go make a billion dollars
someplace else like nobody else can do
that like you know what I mean they
don't seem to understand that
it's a dictator and it's a tyranny and
they're [__] destroying democracy we
got to kill all those civilians make all
this money get the [__] out of here
you know
America's got to learning something
right now
is they just gotta [__] live at peace
with other nations and and [__]
become equal with them and the American
ruling class doesn't want that because
that their whole banking system their
whole imperial system will fall apart
which is that's what what England was
doing
okay back in the 1700s
yeah this whole idea that America is
going to have to live as an equal with
China and Russia and India oh our rich
people don't like that at all
not at all but they're just gonna have
to learn that
they're not backwards Savages
maybe they were at one time
but not in not in today's age they have
the same technology or better
and those [__] are smart
yeah India isn't quite as developed as
the United States Russia is doing real
good China's doing good all right those
people are smart
we're talking about the hot weather Camp
guy says buy the biggest dehumidifier
you can get it acts almost as good as an
air conditioner almost well we have air
conditioning in here we don't need them
yeah it's yeah our air conditioning is
we have we actually have two uh outside
air conditioning units because our house
is two stories so it has one for each
one for each floor and it works pretty
good James says China is weak anyway no
you'd you're wrong and Russia's not weak
either America is much weaker
America is much weaker than them we have
[__] horrible [__] recruiting
numbers terrible [__] troop quality
obsolete aircraft obsolete tanks
obsolete [__] um uh submarine
missiles the Tomahawk missile man of
[__] 30 years old 40 years old
even our nuclear Arsenal is out of date
uh the the the entire structure of the
U.S military is just [__] from
another era most of its grift extremely
inefficient
and then it depends upon private
contractors to make all this all this
weaponry and the Weaponry isn't made for
[__] cost Effectiveness that's just
made for [__] profits
so they're always going to sell you some
technophiliac [__] super expensive
weapon that doesn't actually work in
rough conditions
you end up with [__] like the M1
Abrams tank which is a [__] duck I
mean that was good back in the day but
it's got a jet turbine on it man it's a
[__] stupidest [__] engine that
you could put in there it'd be so much
better with a diesel engine I mean that
thing can't even sit the IR signature on
that thing is [__] terrible huge
anyways [__] sank all this money in
useless stealth technology
stealth technology might be good against
a third world country but it's not going
to be good against [__] Russia Russia
doesn't use [__]
[__] uh radar to identify aircraft to
use a [__] like ir and all kinds of they
have all all kinds of other ways and
it's not the era of the jet anyway it's
the era of the Hypersonic missile which
cuts the jet out of the equation you
just launch the [__] missile and it
hits 6 000 miles away
any Target you select and it went Mach 8
the whole way there's no way to [__]
intercept it
so there's no need for jets anymore
this is all expensive trick trinkets
they're good against developing nations
and you like Iraq but Iraq was like
beaten up on a child okay it was a
third-rate military
and I was in during that war
it was easy to destroy I mean [__]
they were a third rate military like
something out of the [__] 60s
Russia's [__] Cutting Edge now and
they're lying on the news all their
backwards they're nah that's all lies as
Zircon missiles the [__] so is that
[__] kinjal
and they got a great [__] uh true
quality
their infantries and their their their
tankers are [__] superb
uh I've seen I've seen daily battle data
I [__] watch the the the real news of
what's Happening
they [__] destroyed the the Ukrainian
Army over three times over
and that was the strongest army in
Western Europe it was stronger than
Germany about five times
about 15 times stronger than England you
could [__] you you could fit the
entire [__] armed forces of England
in the [__] Houston Astrodome there's
not many dudes
Russia was destroying that every two
months
their numbers were [__] great
it was just
the world war one style artillery war
with a bunch of drones
those drones just [__] changed the
game
I saw the [__] footage
drone coming flying down and [__]
hitting the dude and blow it up just a
little bit like and it's like a drone
you look like you'd buy it in a store or
something
wasn't anything fantastic they're just
using them right
drone with a grenade strapped onto it
thank you very much Titanic discussions
what do you say your review for 1979's
prophecy alone is worth this thank you
very much have a great night by the way
your thoughts on 1978's Dawn of the Dead
we did we never review that I love Donna
I love Donna dead that's probably oh I
don't know terrible acting but it was
just a cool story
I don't know if I'd go that far yeah I
don't know if I'd go that
but I don't know that might be my
favorite I don't know because I kind of
feel like Night of the Living Dead is
probably my favorite out of all of those
but
because there's just something about the
the original
but Dawn of the Dead is definitely up
there and it could be
going from day to day but yeah [__]
prophecy yeah we just reviewed that not
too long ago didn't we that's the
mutated bear one yeah I love all those
1970s Eco horror movies man Victor
you're falling to American propaganda we
if we went to war with Russia we'd lose
they're [__] they have military
Supremacy
this is not 1995.
they're more advanced than we are and
tougher they can take a lot of
casualties and just shrug it off
no not not the United States
you kill 20 000 in a week or a month
[__] the United States will [__]
turntail and run
and they're just the recruit The Troop
quality is just [__] you know if you see
who's [__] joining and just [__]
crud you know nothing like it was in the
90s
but uh no Russia won that war which
you'll find out in a couple maybe about
a month or so
but there's no fighting going on not
really
what's left of the Ukraine Army is just
contained in a little pocket they've
been called they've been in cauldronated
is what it's called
Washington DC is just lying they're
saying that well we're still gonna
there's no offensive
Russian army will assuming the Ukraine
Army will Mutiny and kill its own
leaders if you ask them to attack now
they're just they're too they're too
weak
Go restaurant High Desert said I like
the idea of taking refuge in a shopping
mall I think everybody did at the time
because
back in the 80s or you know 70s and 80s
that would have been the best place to
Hole up because it has everything
food weapons shoes clothes all kind of
[__] you know what I mean
but uh but yeah
they got weapons in the model source
yeah I mean that was an actual mall
right that was the um Monroeville Mall
right where they shot that they just
shot it at night
I don't think I've ever been to him and
I've been to a lot of malls in my day
but I don't think I've ever been to a
mall that had a gun store in it
or like a weapon store
now I've been to malls that had sporting
goods stores so maybe
yeah okay I guess so man [__] I remember
like the mall that I where I grew up
had a um tobacco shop in it I remember
that because my grandpa used to go there
I just remember that what was it called
The Tinderbox that's right
that is where he always wanted to go it
was like it always smelled so good in
there like it's like it smelled like
tobacco and they had like all cigars and
a humidor in there and all that kind of
[__] it was like pretty cool it was like
pretty small but
um yeah Tammy said now we would go to a
Sam's Club or a Costco's yeah
holy [__] yeah the Sam's Club they got
all man they got everything in there
they got everything in there but yeah
you'd have to like [__] defend it
because everybody'd be wanting to get in
there
we had to take refuge into Westfield
mall would be screwed yeah like nowadays
it's uh not the same because like half
the [__] mall stores would be empty
the mall that we go to
around here
um this might be the closest mall to us
it's Lake Square Mall that's where we go
to like that's where the movies are and
that's where the Chinese buffet we go to
is
um and that's where the bookstore is
where you get coffee and stuff and
that's about how far is that mall from
us 18 miles yeah something like that
um it's not that's actually not a dead
mall it's not crowded
but it's it's got like decent traffic
and most of the stores
are
um are open so like there's a movie
theater in there there's a couple
anchors there's a belk there's a books a
million there's a Pet Smart
um there's and then there's like a bunch
of smaller shops but it doesn't seem
like there's a lot of empty stuff in
there and it was the same thing with our
old one that we used to go to like um in
Altamonte Springs
that mall was always like really busy so
I think this one oh and you know
um I don't know if I mentioned this on
the show or not but right across from
the Books a Million that we always go to
they opened a Spirit Halloween
so I have to like keep not going in
there because otherwise I'll buy
everything but I went in there the other
day and like looked around and I bought
some like cool
Halloween like fingernails and stuff but
I gotta respond to James yeah James
you're half right the the Russians are
using up their old stock
what that story comes from is this is uh
I guess it was almost a year ago
Russia had a whole bunch of old stuff
old Vehicles old tanks they were like
t-72s some of them were even t-64s just
kind of sitting around in mothball
they gave those out they just handed
them out to the Infantry they said here
here's all the vehicles you want just
take take them and go into Ukraine and
blow [__] up and um dudes the Russian
infantry were jumping into t-72s with
just a couple days of training
and using the tank as what we what we
call the military an assault gun you
don't shoot other tanks with it you just
run up on a village and use the tank gun
to blow up buildings and pill boxes and
[__] like that because it was free they
had a bunch of it I might go get another
drink well the Western media jumped on
that it was like oh man they're using
all this old validation that wasn't the
that wasn't Russian tank units using
that they have a more advanced tank
they were just giving away all the old
[__] to infantry troops as bonus weapons
I'm ex-infantry somebody who came up to
me and I was in a theater like like
Afghanistan and I was just I'm a M60
Gunner
belt fed machine gun they said Ross
instead of that machine gun that M60
would you like a tank you and chaffino
and [__] Sparks we'll give you guys a
tank yeah yeah give us the [__] tank
because you're Bulletproof you're not
missile proof but you're bulletproof and
you don't have to walk you can now ride
and your buddies can jump up on top of
the tank and you can give them a ride to
go down and [__] [__] up Ukrainian
buildings and [__] and that's what they
were doing
oh but yeah they they had old vehicles
with rotten ass tires they said well
instead of walking down here here just
take all these old Vehicles drive them
down there so they did a lot of that but
I think military U.S military
intelligence they knew what the Russians
had done
but they lied on the Russians as
propaganda you know they're using this
old out of that equipment no
they gave that old out of date equipment
to their own troops to use as just bonus
[__] bonus vehicles
that's all it was
it's not what they're doing down there
is not mobile Warfare anyway though it's
like world war one because everything is
a stalemate nothing can fly any jet that
goes into the air is [__] shot down
by the Russians Hypersonic missiles
stealth doesn't work because they'll use
IR detection
they have new new ways of detecting
aircraft
what would you need a jet for
to drop a bomb why drop a bomb when you
can shoot a [__] Hypersonic missile
it'll go even further than the jet a lot
faster no way to stop it there's no crew
surface fleets are a thing of the past
you now have all these [__]
submarine drones that just blow up when
they hit a ship surface drones
aircraft carriers are a thing of the
past
like I said though those are good
against third world countries and that's
what America's been doing I mean [__]
this is what I did for a living that's
what we've been [__] doing for the
past 70 years is beating up on little
third world countries
that's easy to do it's like beating up a
child and still we were losing
because they out endure you if Vietnam
didn't surrender they just kept on going
on you know
same thing with a rock it didn't change
there's no democracy in Iraq I remember
when they sent us to that [__] we're
going to bring democracy to Iraq yeah
whatever they were just grifting making
money that's all it was they'll tell an
American citizen anything and they'll
believe it right or left and the right
Wingers will be like yeah Stars and
Stripes America [__] Chevrolet apple
pie send my son down there
he's just making money
didn't do any good you didn't change
Afghanistan for the better well I think
the better or Vietnam Vietnam got better
because they got rid of us
as soon as we were gone Vietnam got
better America's really not been a force
of good in the world it's been a force
of evil
in general
I would say with the exception of
[__] World War II
and we didn't have much to do with that
in Europe that was mostly us beating up
on the Japanese
well we and I'm not quite sure they
deserved it I don't know if our version
of History was about what the Japanese
were doing in China I'm not sure that's
100 legit
that's the uh that's a U.S historians
talking about the rape of Nanjing and
all that
we put an oral embargo on us and they
[__] retaliated by [__]
we put an oil oil embargo on them and
they retaliated by attacking the fleet
at [__] Pearl Harbor
well could we put an oil embargo on them
without oil they'd [__] starve to
death
they were an industrial country on an
island
and it's always these sanctions we got
to put these sanctions on these people
okay because they did something and said
something we didn't like like we're like
this [__] bully
I've left Japan alone it wouldn't have
been a problem
well you know we do like to throw our
dicks yeah because we think we're better
than everybody yeah we're better than
everybody else we're better than all
these brown and yellow people
yeah I mean
it's not as much like that but I do kind
of particularly when I was younger like
at school I do think that there was that
veneer
they did there they haven't changed
they're just rewording it now it's about
defending democracy
which there's not a democracy here
doesn't matter who you vote for both
parties are [__]
the cats are running around I guess I
keep hearing them back there
they have a new game the two cats do
um little Bambi or Dakota she was Dakota
when she came from the shelter but we
call her Bambi because for various
reasons
um she likes to like hide behind the
door yeah and then like peek out and
then when Pookie comes she's like and
she like jumps on her but so I don't
know
I guess they're friends I can't really
tell they don't hurt each other no they
kind of like but they're not like
they're not really beating up so you
know what I mean
I wanted them to be friends and hang out
so I'm hoping that that's happening they
just like run around like little Buffalo
herds like all the time it's like pretty
funny
it's pretty funny but as I can hear them
like in the background hiding behind the
door and jumping out of each other and
whatnot super funny that's correct po
it's about endurance
Warfare is always about endurance
technology always fails you it's just
whoever [__]
cries Uncle first
just look in history that
and an America cries Uncle first
it's kind of the same thing it's like if
you're in a fist fight with somebody
it's like it's not so much the stronger
person it's the person that can get
their ass whipped and keep looking back
do you wear anything I have over time
yeah
he'll just get sick of like wailing them
yeah and he starts getting tired and
then he when he's tired he's weaker and
then you start beating up on him and
he's like oh [__] it so there's
something to be said for you know having
a talent for like getting your ass beat
and then just getting back up again
you'll Outlast everybody that way
because even the strongest person has to
get tired sometimes yeah and and the
American Military doesn't really
understand that because they don't want
to understand that because that would
cost them a lot of money
see after World War II
Operation Paperclip we got a lot of the
ex-german guys over here scientists
military thinkers strategists
so we started to emulate the German
combined arms Warfare which is what was
back in the day was called Blitzkrieg
tactics okay we use infantry armored and
air power all at once and lightning
strikes lots of maneuver moving using
Telecommunications
capturing one key Point moving on to the
next this and that
that didn't work all right the Germans
lost their war and so what we did is we
attack we we [__] adapted the
thinking and the strategies and the and
the and and the military equipment
we adapted we adapted the thinking of
The Losers of World War II not the
winners the winners was was the Soviet
Union and the Soviet Union was about
endurance and production and numbers
yeah they had these badass tanks but
they were cheap and when they got
destroyed they were instantly replaced
with two tanks and when you destroyed
those two tanks they were replaced with
four tanks so it was a war of production
and mass just overwhelming them over
time too
where you could just hold an enemy off
for a year and then in the rear you're
building up huge surpluses of [__]
weaponry and then the beginning of year
two you just swap them with all this
[__] material that you made
that's what the Russians do and that's
what they just did they're the [__]
masters of it world-class [__] land
Warfare Specialists because they don't
have a military-industrial complex all
the weapons factories are government
owned run by basically military guys and
they just sit there on idle not making
much as soon as the war happens they
start massive production a year later
you're swamped by a [__] ton of material
and it was all cheap
one-sixth what we would pay for it and
side by side quality better actually
more reliable simpler faster to make
well not as high tech but you don't want
technology and warfare you want numbers
and speed of production
you know you have the best [__] tank
in the world but if it takes [__] six
months to make it it's too low it's too
slow
you want to take the you want to take it
you can make it six days not six months
well it's just kind of like I say about
even [__] consumer goods and stuff
like that I'm always a big fan of just
like buying [__] that doesn't have a
bunch of bells and whistles on it
because to me that's like more [__] to
break more [__] to break I just want
[__] that's simple that's not what it
does
the tank is supposed to run in the snow
adverse conditions
and be fuel economy have a good fuel
efficiency it has some steel armor so
machine guns don't shoot through it
there's no way you're going to stop
those tank routes don't worry about it
if it gets hit by a tank round it's
going to be destroyed
and right now
you hit a [__] M1 Airbus with an
anti-tank around it's destroyed it
doesn't matter that it's [__] seven
times the price of a 272. it's still
destroyed they're both destroyed right
doesn't matter
yeah it's got a jet engine on it [__] it
goes 65 miles an hour yeah but it
guzzles fuel it drinks fuel like crazy
and it can't just sit there at idle for
days without burning much fuel like a
[__] diesel engine can do you know
just
our weapons were made for profit
to so the military-industrial profit
would make a lot of cash so they could
buy swimming pools and have side side
chicks so they could get a side chick
they just because
a commission on it
lots of serviceability a lot of [__] you
got to buy to keep it running because it
they made money on that that's good for
them it's not good for the guy in the
field
it's not good for winning wars unless
you're fighting little third world
countries
you know it's like beating up on a baby
but when you fight a real country like
Russia or China it's about numbers
I heard somebody saying China's [__]
weak China would [__] us up in a land
Warfare there's so many of them
and just because what they're Oriental
they don't know how to fight
I assume yeah they maybe they don't know
how to swim because a lot of them never
learn to swim when they're kids but you
don't need to learn how to swim to eat
your [__] driving APC and [__]
operate a machine gun the Chinese fought
like [__] devils in [__] Vietnam
and in Korea
against us they were [__] human wave
attacks and [__]
the Chinese are good Fighters you just
swarm you like the Zerg attacking Africa
Starker Starcraft they just send
millions of Imagine
High Desert says get a TV now it's no
longer just plug it in and turn it on
you have to spend an hour program yeah
yeah which yeah they make money and
maybe and maybe this is like the old
person and look I'm not saying it's like
look I like all that [__] I like all the
new [__] that we have now and if I want
to know how to do it I will figure it
out but ninety percent of the stuff like
the features that a lot of stuff comes
with now I will never use and I think
most people will never use even if
they're not old like me
like I can figure out how to use a TV I
can figure out because I'm good at like
computer [__] I always have been so it's
like you know I'll figure it out but
like I said most of the [__] that it
comes with I don't need it
you know
holy [__] man it's like now they have
those refrigerators that are like oh we
take a picture of everything in your
refrigerator and we send you an alert
that you're out of [__] and I was like I
don't need that I I can open it it takes
a second I can open it be like Oh I'm
almost out of milk I better go to the
store and get some I don't I don't need
the computer to tell you that PO you are
100 correct man you get my point post
said complexity does not endure it does
not endure
no and it does not endure in extreme
conditions and warfare is in extreme
condition
extreme climactic conditions lots of
stress on the men nothing's been cleaned
nobody's been bathed in a while [__]
it's it the temperatures are exceedingly
low during the winter
so yeah you want equipment that can be
neglected and abused and continue to run
some of our [__] was like that when I
was in but a lot of it wasn't
it was very maintenance heavy which
required a lot of [__]
support from maintenance units so things
like tanks and [__] had to be offline
being worked on for a lot of period of
time then they go out and kick ass but
then you have to pull it back again and
work on it they're there's this kind of
same problem with German Panthers you
know like the pants are [__] six and
the pants are seven they're King Tiger
and all that [__] they looked great on
paper and when they were running they
were [__] badasses but Germany didn't
have the [__] support
Network to keep those things running in
the field the [__] Transmissions
would blow on them they were so
overweight over
over weighted down and underpowered
transmissions and
they were just trying to get the biggest
baddest thing out there as quickly as
they could
interleaved road wheels for a real
smooth ride try to give a super high
quality it didn't matter
fighting the Russians
okay
Russian winner forget [__] it up and
then just not being able to maintain it
would [__] it up
the road wheels need to have bearings on
it was just plain bearings they were
pumping grease to it because ball
bearing factories got blown up just
you know the more complicated more
complicated there's more [__] it is
a tank of the war was the [__] t-34
but it was a Russian tank and it was
just like a caveman tank you could make
a lot of them and they were good they
were very survivable you could make them
rapidly they were cheap
they were good in the hands of a right
crew they were real good they were
[__] the the Panzer five Panther
was a response to the [__] t-34 they
tried to make it more like a t-34 but
with better quality road wheels and this
and that which
complicated it again they should have
just made a copy of the t-34 you know
which is half the price you can make it
half the time you know and it was just
as good so
it's called de-engineering
a real engineer minimizes the amount of
moving Parts doesn't maximize them you
want you want to get the job done with
the fewest amount of Parts possible
I mean that seems like it would just be
common sense yeah yeah but when you
can't overthink [__] like that right but
when profit is is well then all that
[__] comes in yeah yeah and Americans
are technophiles they love [__] high
technology [__]
in Warfare ground combat stuff you don't
want it to be high tech you want to be
low-tech but reliable and Powerful yeah
effective cost effective and cheap
now
Russians have these Hypersonic missiles
they are super high tech so and some
things are high-tech we can't make those
those are 10 years away from us
because we make [__] based on computer
programs and [__] the Zircon and the
[__] kinjal missile were made with
fun slide rules and people thinking
about [__] in their heads Russians are
[__] smart okay they didn't use a
computer program to come up with a
because the Hypersonic air coming into a
combustion chamber we don't know how to
do it but somebody over there figured
out how to do it
it's some kind of a mathematical
algorithm
that they know
which is the same thing in Jets jet
turbines there's a bunch of math you
have to know in order to successfully
produce a working jet turbine if you
don't know those theorems you'll never
get it done they figured out some kind
of medical Theory there to get
hypersonics done
we've been trying for [__] decades
and couldn't get it done
they know something we don't post says
complexity is highly profitable however
yes combine that with planned
obsolescence yeah and the bankers win
not you yeah yeah like boots on the
ground you do need [__] that is simple
that generally works better
like I said less [__] to break it's true
in Warfare it's true in consumer goods
it's true in everything like everybody
loves night vision but when I was in the
service we hated night vision night
vision goggles for infantry use you
needed batteries
and it didn't matter once [__]
bullets are flying tracers were flying
you could see anyway because all that
[__] was lighting up though right didn't
matter they were good for certain things
looking across fields and stuff but you
wanted your own natural night vision to
be pretty good
and um
night vision and IR lasers that's good
for certain specific problems but that
wasn't general purpose you can't depend
on batteries you know in a in a real war
yeah you don't really know like when are
you gonna get resupply right
so it just seems like just try to keep
things as simple as possible yeah they
worked for us in these past Wars because
we're beating up on babies
so the supplies were coming right but if
you went to war with a real country
supplies would stop coming because those
planes would be shut and then you'd be
shut down then you'd be [__] hosed
yeah it goes back to caveman technology
well see that's what I always said
that's why in the case of a zombie
apocalypse yes I'm getting a bicycle and
a sandwich
that's all I need and I'm just gonna I'm
just gonna bike from place to place and
cut people's heads up Swords don't need
ammo they don't need [__] they don't
need ammo they don't need they don't
need anything they don't need anything
they don't need anything it's perfect
and the bicycle the thing about it yeah
bicycle could break down or your tire
could go flat or something like that but
there's tons of bicycles laying around
you could just find another one you know
what I mean it's not that big catch a
tire yeah it's not you don't need
gasoline you don't need anything dizzy
it would go back to like [__] simple
yeah the bicycle is a good survival tool
people forget that bicycles when they
came out was the when they first came
out they were the highest technology
item mankind could produce it was a big
deal they were they were replacing
horses with bicycles
especially multi-speed bicycles that was
a mind-blowing [__] to those people
based on that technology the right
brothers made an aircraft yep using Tech
using bicycle technology because bicycle
they owned a bicycle shop yep bicycles
and then motorcycles which is just a
motorized bicycle right you take those
motorcycle and bicycle technology put
together if you if you know basic
aerodynamics which the Wright brothers
really kind of didn't no basic
aerodynamics they were I mean they were
like uh it was they did some wind tunnel
testing about prop pitch what was the
best pitch for prop was but they didn't
figure about figure out [__] things
like control services like ailerons and
flaps and [__] they used Wing warping
they would warp the entire Wing to get a
turn that's [__] dangerous it doesn't
work well
the rights fly the right flyer was
[__] hard to fly dangerous they they
kind of went about it in a trial and
error fashion
which isn't the best way to go about
something that can kill you like that
but you know yeah but then a few decades
later they were [__] Folker mono
planes and [__] which looked really
[__] modern you know they weren't
even biplanes they were just [__]
single wing model I still you know what
I see you remember that show that used
to be on I guess it was on the History
Channel it was like about
um like dogfights like airplane dog
fights
um I especially admire the brass cojones
of the dudes that got in those [__]
world war one yeah planes man and got up
there in the air and we're like shooting
it I'm like holy [__] [__] you would
not give me that it was a glorified kite
that's what I mean and it's just like
that's crazy to me that like dudes were
crazy enough to like in the end get up
in that [__] and just like that's that's
insane those engines that they had and
then [__] knows wouldn't even make a
decent motorcycle engine
you know I know that's what that's what
blows my mind about that [__] they've
even put out 100 horse that people are
like hey get in that [__] and like go up
there and like shoot at them and he's
like okay
I don't even like to fly in a regular
ass airplane yeah much less fly around
like a little [__] thing that's made
of like spit and wood and paper yeah you
know plywood which most of it was right
but still plywood was real [__] high
tech in the day I know it was a lot of
it was playing with canvas and then
something called dope painted over it
was like shellac yeah would Harden it
and uh but there wasn't much to those
they're just wire control surfaces and
stuff
um
you you literally could build that in
your backyard and then put a motorcycle
engine in it yeah same [__] it would
[__] outrun it it outperform it yeah
but it's just yeah like I said I really
I really admire the [__] Blitz but of
like people that would get in those and
like fly them around in the sky and [__]
because I absolutely would not do that
you could pull that 1200 cc V-Twin
Harley-Davidson fuel motor that I have
out of that motorcycle and put that in
the nose and of a [__] World War One
stop with camel or something and it
would outperform the camel
because it was lighter and putting out
probably about the same horsepower but
hundreds of pounds lighter that motor
yeah those Motors were heavy they didn't
put much power out
and then the radial stuck and didn't
have engine seals the whole [__] the
fact that they actually flew kind of
blows my mind
[Laughter]
those multicelli cylinder radio Motors
[__] spun right along with the prop
the whole engine turning and it wasn't
you really couldn't get a good seal on
the engine
so they fill a castor oil and castor oil
will blow out of the [__] engine and
all over you'll be all over your face
and [__] yep see me tasting castor oil
all [__] day yeah right this is not a
pleasant experience
Zach says one wonders how anyone managed
to ride these penny farthings with the
giant front wheels I always wondered
about those who on earth like why would
that occur to you to make the front
wheel way bigger than the back you
didn't have any [__] differential
gears so it made it made it easier to
[__] pedal and you could go faster if
the front wheel was bigger
yeah you go faster probably not easier
to Pedal
it almost kind of looked at least from
the drawings it kind of looked like you
needed a [__] step ladder to get off
yeah I don't I think you had to get on
Sideways and you had to [__] yeah
throw like my short asses and getting on
there that's for sure those weren't
around for very long though they weren't
now like everybody figured out oh well
let's do the same essentially uh you
came up with things that look kind of
look like 10 speeds the first
Harley-Davidson looked like a 10-speed
kind of
yeah a gas tank on it a little twin
two-cylinder engine in it
Gen X Jason said it's amazing how
quickly technology has evolved in such a
short span of time yeah it's when I kind
of stop and think about it sometimes I'm
like holy [__] man you could go back
50 years just 50 years
um you know 50 years 100 years whatever
and bring somebody back here in a time
they're [__] they wouldn't know what
the [__] was going on look how different
it is
and it's like we kind of take it for
granted because like I said we were here
for the whole thing so we were just kind
of like oh here's this new thing but if
you brought somebody from even like from
the 1950s which I guess is 70 years ago
now that I'm thinking about it but if
you brought somebody even from the 1950s
into the modern era they wouldn't know
what the [__] was going on
you can show them the [__] and there
they'd be like holy crap it's like
[__] sci-fi internet cell phones at
[__] about that's what I'm saying they
would just think of a science fiction
that you could just take a [__] out of
your pocket and it's like hey what do
you want to know
I got Maps I got this that and
everything I think it's science fiction
one day I had a pager
had a telephone I remember those and
then cell phones started to come they
were [__] expensive
and then eventually [__] the moderate
cell phone came you could so I went from
a self a pager to a cell phone
yeah you know what I mean I remember you
having that little flip phone yeah that
flips a flip phone yeah because I've
known you for a long time like I think I
Met You in 2009
yeah you had a Motorola flip phone back
then yeah because I remember you like
texting me on that yeah it also had like
a backup radio
[Laughter]
that's handy
and all kinds of [__] that you would
never need
but it was expensive in the day yeah
they were hugely expensive yeah and it
was what was good about it is working on
working on the farm is that you could
drop it in water it was totally
waterproof
nothing would happen to it yeah yeah it
was totally waterproof
that's crazy it was indestructible and I
dropped it all the time because you
should go flying [__] bouncing around
it made it it had a little color LCD
screen
yeah I remember I remember that one you
could you could you could see what was
happening it wasn't HD but it didn't
matter for the day it was pretty cool
now it was a big step up from a pager
yeah you can get [__] you could do
texts you could get email
yeah you could surf the web a little bit
yeah
but yeah that was um
I I think that people for if you didn't
grow up in the 1980s I think you forget
how expensive just [__] VCRs were
yeah in the early yeah there were
thousands of dollars like in the 19
early 1980s because I remember we got
one well we had a betamax first and then
we got like a VCR like a regular vcr and
I think my dad had well he got it like
second hand and I think it was like 1500
and that was like for a second hand one
my mind got blown in the 90s
I guess there's mid to late 90s when I
went to the store and saw VCR for twenty
dollars oh a VCR for [__] twenty
dollars yeah I was like wow that used to
be so expensive it was like a huge deal
[__]
and you could get a TV with a VCR in it
for a hundred yeah we had one of those
the yeah color TV yeah we had a t
actually we had a TV that had a VCR in
it and we also had a dual deck VCR so
then you could rent movies and pirate
them if it didn't have macrovision if
you remember that and in like the
[__] middle to late 2000s
I had a little thing that's like a
laptop you could open it up it had an
LCD screen you could put a DVD in it and
[__] watch a movie off of it oh I
remember those yeah I never had one but
I have one around here somewhere maybe I
threw it out there were about 60 70 at
the time yeah and then they plummeted it
down they don't even think they exist
anymore yeah I don't think anybody makes
them and if some if you did find that
China probably still has [__] like that
probably 20 bucks
how should I bet yeah 20 bucks for a
good one
the weird thing about just DVDs portable
now you know right [__] on your phone
well yeah and well and that's the thing
it's like I kind of feel like
um I mean we still have some DVD I still
have some DVDs but I can play them in my
computer
still so it's like so I'm not really
worried but I don't we don't have a DVD
player we have an Xbox and that'll play
will that play that'll play DVDs right
yep that plays DVDs yeah
doesn't doesn't do it'll do 4K but I
have a television for it yeah that's
right like you can put the 4K in there
and it'll be like yeah your TV isn't
like isn't doing that [__]
but it's just it's funny like to think
about just in our lifetimes like how
much [__] and we don't like I said we
don't really
I don't really think about it all that
much because it's like yeah yeah it was
a long time ago but I do remember when
bcrs were like thousands of dollars
video cameras for thousands of dogs and
my dad was like real into
um you know he always want to have the
big video cameras and so he bought one
like in the 80s well I think he bought
that second hand too
but I don't remember how much he paid
for it but it was massive it was like
this big [__] massive
[__] movie camera thing like that and
it's just oh my God it's [__]
hilarious to like think how much [__] is
progressed since then and like I said I
think if you even if you possibly hear
from the 70s they're probably a [__]
mind movie Blown you know what I mean
ah
yeah uh James says remember when DVDs
were the new thing yeah
um I still specifically remember and
this was probably back in the 90s
because I was a little bit late because
you know I I never had a lot of money so
I was never like on The Cutting Edge of
technology I always had to like wait so
I didn't even get a CD player until
probably like the early 1990s or the
late 1980s maybe like everybody already
had one and I was like finally I got one
because that was all cassettes before
that I couldn't afford a CD player
I think I got a DVD player
in
mid 90s I want to say which is probably
like a little later than a lot of people
got them and I you know what's crazy I
still remember the first movie that I
bought on DVD and it was Amadeus because
I love that [__] movie I still love
that [__] movie and I had it on VHS
and when I got a DVD player that was the
first movie I wanted again
on DVD and I watched it and I was like
wow like it looked so much better you
know what I mean and it was just it's
just like funny it's funny to think
about that
it says remember when Marconi's for the
new thing we're not that old
we're not that old
but yeah you guys what I made today oh
yeah he's working on his Bane costume
yeah this is my Bane armband put it in
got it in today already didn't get it in
today I've got got it done today I built
it yeah he made it I'm gonna go in here
these rivets I don't really like how
these rivets can't I'm going I'm gonna
sew it I got my leather kit and [__]
punch bunch of holes in there
reinforce it
but uh I was soaking it today starting
to get yeah that looks really
starting to get better I'm still
wondering like what because like I said
I don't have a lot of money so I just
kind of wondering like what I'm gonna do
for Halloween like because initially I
was like I want to do the werewolf thing
and I was like wow that might be too
expensive and then I was thinking like
Predator that also might be too
expensive
it's working out yeah it looks good yeah
it looks good yeah
yeah I'm laughing at yeah there you go
see that looks awesome
you're giving it away Tom
I got the shirt coming today yeah
supposed to be here
or maybe tomorrow I guess yeah
he's been working on it he's been
working on it yeah I got most of the
rest of the outfit then I have to do the
vest but I may I could do it shirtless
though too because in the movie he
didn't have a shirt on yeah any excuse
not to wear a shirt Tom well I go I got
another shirt like this coming that's uh
coyote brown yeah that I can wear with
the I got the pants I got the boots I
got the [__] combat pants and
everything
but I could wear that t-shirt
if I can't get the bulletproof see I
wanted the vest to actually be
Bulletproof
I mean yeah level three that's always a
plus yeah
it's gonna be threat level three
which means it'll stop most pistol
rounds with not rifle rounds in case any
in case Batman's shooting at you
no I wanted to look at it you go no
that's not a costume that's a real
[__] thing well yeah that's I kind of
always like that too if you're gonna do
a Halloween costume you're gonna do it
right man yeah
um Gen X Jason said my first CD I had
was The Cure kiss me kiss me kiss me I
remember my first actually my first
cassette
was The Cure the walk
the first CD that I bought was
extricate by the Fall
and I very much remember because I was
very excited to buy it
but um but yeah
so I still remember that too I still
remember that too it says delivered the
18th
the 18th that was four days ago three
days September 18th yeah that was oh no
no it's the 22nd look at the wrong one
it's
okay now the shirt's running late okay
you got plenty of time yeah
I was kind of I was looking on Etsy the
other day
like for costume ideas because I was I
don't like to just do [__] that
everybody else is doing you know what I
mean I like to come up with something
original
um somebody on there was selling this
really cool kind of like love crafty and
like octopus kind of
outfit
and I was I was kind of into it like
it's kind of like a body suit but it
also has like all these tentacles and
stuff it's really really cool looking
and so I was kind of like I kind of want
it but it's like 150 and I was like oh I
can't afford that but it looks awesome
I don't know so then I thought well
maybe I should do something like
lovecraftian but I can't think of
anything specific
another idea I had that would be kind of
cheap was
um if you guys have seen the movie
uh Alice Sweet Alice
from the 70s
I was thinking about doing this last
year
um the murderer in that that has like
the yellow raincoat and like the face
like the mask that kind of looks like a
face with makeup on it but it's kind of
clear like and then like she goes around
stabbing people I thought about doing
that to you but I'm not sure you asked
me to do the voice yeah you gonna do the
voice it seems like it seems like
victory has defeated you Batman
I haven't seen that movie in such a long
time I don't remember this voice that
again
yeah you gotta practice dude you gotta
practice
yeah I was just laughing at Pokemon you
merely adopted the darkness I was born
to it
yeah I wanted to do like some kind of
they have like some cool like um Cthulhu
like masks and stuff which I kind of
liked
um I don't know
I saw like on Etsy they have like a
bunch of really cool bodysuits and they
had some that were like
um that look like biomechanical
and I kind of like that and then I was
thinking oh maybe I should dress up like
you know the um you know the old Fritz
Lang movie Metropolis yeah like the
robot in that I was like oh maybe I
should do that oh that robot would be
expensive to me I know but that yeah but
that then that's what I'm saying it's
like man because because the head is
like really really distinctive so you'd
have to like either buy it or you'd have
to make it yourself which I don't really
have the skills for
but
see that's the kind of [__] I don't I
don't like my one of my rules about
Halloween costumes and I've broken it a
few times one of my rules is that I
don't really want to be anything that
you could buy an off-the-shelf
costume for you know what I'm saying
largely I don't so
I mean I've done it before like I was I
did Medusa last year was it last year or
the year before did I did the Medusa
thing but I made my own you know what I
mean I didn't just buy one
off the thing
um TBD Dragon says Tom what stack or
cycle was Tom Hardy or Bane on uh you
probably know he never said
but I looked at his physique at the time
I'm an admirer of Tom Hardy in a street
he has a new movie coming out Tammy sent
me a
preview or like a trailer
um it looks good I saw videos of him
training and what he was doing
he was in the gym lifting weights he had
some trainers [__] with him he's
picking [__] up and throwing it over his
head
um
he did not get very lean he kind of got
big around the middle he looked a little
bit bloated
which leads me to believe that it was
the testosterone and Deanna ball
probably injectable Deanna ball
which I've taken that and that gives you
kind of a bloated look kind of a hamster
look in your face again I've got a
picture of it [__] my driver's
license I was on [__] d-ball on my
driver's license yeah
it didn't even look like me
and he was like so upset they took the
picture and he's like oh my God my head
looks like a bowling yeah
was in an interesting compound
it's on the it's on the testosterone
Branch so it's not DHT and it's not 19
North testosterone which is testosterone
it's like a super testosterone
um some it's like a synthetic
testosterone molecule the carbon in a
slightly a different
location
and what it does is it um it has
it feels great in terms of like feeling
good I would say
Deanna ball was
one of the best feeling ones
Trend was even better but it makes you
[__] crazy all right um but Tiana
ball felt good you walk around slinky
sexy you think you're a [__] Top Cat
you think everything's trying to [__]
you and you're ready to [__] anything
that comes your way you're just [__]
stupid [__] thing but you look
like [__]
because what ends up happening I loved
your delivery yeah
what happens is is that that
super testosterone molecule aromatizes
into a [__] something called methyl
estrogen which is a [__] type of
estrogen that's not normally inside a
human body I don't think any animals
make methyl estrogen which causes causes
a buildup of it in your system which
makes you feel sexy as a [__]
Okay and make you feel [__] great
you're swimming into orgasm like a
female type [__] you know women just
because they don't ever come they just
kind of [__] swim just leave it like
that yeah we have a long discussion
about the the differences between
imagine you take sex and morphine and
combine and inject it that's kind of way
the animal feels all right
but methyl estrogen builds up in your
body and it's a lot harder for your
system to get rid of methyl estrogen
versus just regular estrogen so you get
real water retention yeah
so I'm looking at
[Laughter]
it was known
for building a lot of muscle quickly
but I don't think the reputation was
justified I didn't really build any
muscle on it
some maybe but I think regular
testosterone would have been
probably just as effective and and
probably would have been less water
retention
it's been smarter probably just a
instead of going like 200 testosterone
and 200 a week
to add a ball probably better just go
400 testosterone a week it'll probably
have been even better you'd looked
better too because I mean hilarious that
you're like walking around thinking
you're like God
and you're like sloshing when you're
like walking here you don't care man
you're too sexy to care
that doesn't happen all at once it takes
a couple months for it to really quickly
start about backing up on you and you
look like a [__] hamster
your hamster head hamster [__] Jesus
but then you're rocking around like yeah
yeah yeah yeah hamster head oh my God
[Laughter]
hormones they're no joke yeah so
looking at look at him
at him looks like test and Deanna ball
injectable the animal there's a pill
version of the animal it's even worse
you hold even more water with that I
think he he has money and he had
trainers I think they gave him Debo
maybe I think it's what it was supposed
to because he when he got that role they
said he cried
he wanted it really bad he wanted it
really bad and he didn't think he could
live up to it because if you see how
Bane is drawn and comic books or even
[__] cartoon movies he's [__] huge
he's [__] huge
and Bane's on steroids he's got his own
special steroid called Venom that he
takes and it [__] makes him [__]
huge if he needs it he hits a butt he
gets bigger than he was
some versions of it just like Tom that's
why you see that big green injection
system he's got on there
um
so
and Tom Hardy
does not have a Heritage of being a big
badass [__] evil looking dude he's a
pretty boy
yeah I mean he's pretty lean he's in
he's he he's he he's not big he was not
big [__] Zach sent me a picture of
him [__] off of Old his old MySpace
page and the [__] had some
killer back arch the whole game world I
love that picture yeah I'm like oh my
gosh look at that that's just called
that's awesome I can't even do that he's
using he's using male energy to just
suck
suck the dick into the booties with like
it's like it's like it's like a black
hole right exactly like gravity well
that's why I love that picture I love
that picture maybe that's how I'm not
saying I'm not saying he's gay I'm just
saying he does have gay appeal [__]
yeah a lot of gay guys liked him yeah he
knew how to get ahead in his career he's
a [__] great actor he he does he
gives his all he's he's a one of the
best modern actors oh yeah easily yeah
he's a little bit Typecast but still he
[__] he does a good job in the in the
in the roles that he's given
um
he was very upset about getting the Bane
because he knew that he could not get
that big right the amount of time that
he was getting
so I think that's why they went to
d-ball because they knew that d-ball
will give you kind of a bigger puffier
look yeah and some versions of bandwid
was drawn he also had a belly on him
right and d-ball will give you a [__]
big Michelin Man kind of [__] build
out of nowhere
so it was uh I think it was a
it was kind of like a better gamble to
go with Deanna ball
he could have got a little bigger using
other stuff like [__] deca
but he wouldn't have looked that
it would have been drier
it depends on how much he took MPP had
been a real dry [__] they've been
[__] looked like [__] Sylvester
Stallone at a [__] Rocky three
yeah awesome and been acting like yeah
yeah maybe yeah
Trent turns me into a total psycho yeah
and you're you're kind of halfway there
as it is even without that so you don't
really need that on top of it no yeah I
literally start thinking about killing
dudes yeah so I think I'm gonna kill
that dude
and you're kind of serious but you what
happens is that you're you you
um the subject changes too quick you
don't really like stick on
you don't like
you don't [__] uh get hung up on
anything real long you're kind of
although but yeah like that whole time I
was kind of either afraid that you were
gonna kill somebody and go to prison
yeah or you were gonna kill me yeah well
the weird thing is is that Jenny thought
I was hostile towards but I didn't feel
any Hospital well I know but you seemed
like that but yeah I wasn't though
because of your like just the way I was
acting yeah like we're erratic like it
didn't seem like that to you but it
seemed like it was me yeah you're it's a
very
okay I've been on all the all the
hormones he's done all of them pretty
much all of them uh I haven't done
equipose or EQ I haven't done that okay
yeah that's the only one that's probably
the only one you have in town uh there's
a couple of like there's you've done
most of them there's a couple of like
exotic ones that aren't really useful I
haven't done there's probably three or
four they have none
and um
I've done also LSD
Tran is the closest to LSD I've ever
done in terms of like mind-altering
drugs it's like a mind-altering hormone
but it didn't chill you out no at all no
it makes you extremely hyper masculine
you want to defend every female you care
about
and you do this by driving every male
out
yeah especially if he's a weak male
but then you come and be you become
aligned
to bigger more ruthless males than you
so it becomes very Animal Kingdom
like you see a big [__] scary
[__] I'm vibing with yeah yeah
yeah I get along with that guy great I
see a little weedy 80 pound [__]
I want to kill him I don't want him
around
which kind of brings back certain
memories in the past
where jock type dudes [__] acted
aggressive towards me without any when I
was a kid without any warning that maybe
what that is probably what it is because
trend's been around for a long time yeah
trembling
and it's well known for causing yeah
those types of Summer effects
and you know
I've never had Roid Rage per se
except the trend I want to say that you
could probably call that Roid Rage it's
not really rage in the way you would
think it's more like a [__] simmering
evil
you feel like doctor like Mr Hyde
from Dr Jacob Mr you feel like that like
what was his name [__] that dude who
[__] played Gladiator what's his name
uh Russell Russell and Russell Crowe and
Tom Cruise when they did that scene with
[__] from The Mummy when he meets
[__] Dr Jekyll and he turns into Mr
Hyde yeah I was like oh Tom vibed with
that really yeah yeah that's it when we
saw that movie yeah he's like yeah okay
yeah yeah
start vibing with that
with uh what's his name Osborne
the goblin the goblin yeah yeah the
Wilderness
yeah be like that
so it's not good I did not recommend
Tran but see you had a good time on it
see that's what's scary about it because
uh James is saying I avoid people as I'm
very anti-social yeah same
um so Trend seems to be an avoid at all
costs thing yeah the scariest thing
about Trend to me like from the outside
was that the person that's on it feels
amazing yeah and you can't tell them
that anything's wrong that anything's
wrong because they don't believe you
yeah so it's like Tom's acting like a
complete psychopath yeah and you could
be like hey can you not like tear
people's heads off or can you not like
do this and that he's like [__] that
whatever like he just feels amazing and
awesome so it's like you can't like he
thinks you're just like making it up so
it's like it's really really scary
because you can't yeah you talk them
down from you gotta go through this maze
it took me a while to kind of go no I am
acting I am acting wrong but like
several people had to tell you yeah
before you really can and I had to kind
of like go yeah this is this is wrong
you see
any kind of trend stack they tell you
and that's what to run that longer than
90 days
yeah [__] man that's three months I was
on the ship for five [__] he was on
it for five months and like I said I
didn't know right I didn't even find out
until after because I found out after
that he'd been telling Sophie about it
because he thought well I don't know if
you thought this but you thought that I
was cheating on you
one day I thought that every now and
then I think and then I was like no it
can't be because you kept going in your
man cave and like being and I was like
what the [__] is his problem because I
didn't know that you were on no I was
just going to the man cave to [__]
try to
separate myself from [__] reality
right get away from other people yeah
but no I only thought that for like one
day
but I was like I would never well I was
like well no I knew it was an illusion
yeah because I'd already been I'd
already I didn't know this until after
yeah I already knew that I already knew
that tread's notorious for that right oh
yeah that's another thing it's notorious
for it if you have a girlfriend or wife
you will absolutely think that she's
cheating on you yeah so I already
expected that right
so when I started it took a long time
that was like month five
yeah and I was gonna have been cheating
on me and I was like but how she never
goes anywhere I'm like I work at home I
don't go anyplace but that would just go
into like a [__] circle in my head
over and over again anyway so I had to
come in and he says you're not cheating
on me you're like no okay it's okay I
didn't think you were even if I was
going someplace I would never do that
anyway yeah I'm just not that kind of
person but then like he's gonna she
cheated on me in the past though so that
it comes now it's like the devil it's
having the devil in you yeah but then
you go no I didn't think that before
it's because I'm on Trend I'm thinking
yeah so you know yeah that's the only
reason because you weren't right you
like that but you can't think you can
think your way out of it
but
the thing is I felt great I didn't want
to come off of it I didn't stayed on it
forever well even now you're kind of
like I kind of want to go back you know
I'm just like you better not
it
it kind of has a very seductive feeling
to it a [__] megalomania you just you
feel so [__] powerful
yeah you kind of feel like you're like
God of the world yeah you're like you
said [__] like that yeah you feel like
you had this god-like status you're just
like better than ever but I can kill
whoever the [__] I want to like I could
die and it won't even affect me you're
like yeah that's like yeah it was great
it doesn't matter you were saying all
kind of yeah yeah like you were better
than everybody like you were the [__]
king of the world like [__] like that
yeah yeah I'm just crazy bulletproof
they shoot me yeah I [__] get killed
but it won't matter because I'll be
intact in the spirit world you're just
[__] nuts yeah yeah it's nutty it was
it was uh it wasn't right I'm
experienced infantry [__] Airborne
infantry Soldier but had [__] trained
by [__] Army Rangers and [__] have
some other training and [__] which is
Ranger trading is just about how much
[__] you can endure but
so I know what
[__] combat infantry combats like
if if there's ever a go to war drug it'd
be Tran
oh yeah I can see that yeah that would
be very effective yeah and it's life or
death [__] situation where it's gonna
be a suicide mission or you're in the
[__] apocalypse and you've got to
survive the next couple years we're Gods
on Earth if you had a law if you had
several years [__] worth the [__]
trend
yeah you do well because you'd wipe out
[__] all your yeah all the yeah
because all of your people would be
completely crazy yeah
yeah you just completely said what you
would preempt you would preemptively
attack people so they couldn't hurt you
yeah later right you'd be your yeah
because you did that all the time [__]
man we pulled out of our driveway at our
old house we pulled out of our tribe at
our old house and like a guy was like
kind of blocking the road a little bit
like because they were there was a party
at the neighborhood now I got out and
want to be there and he was going to be
I'm just like Tom from what why like
it's fine he's moving I was driving
I was driving oh my God driving a car I
was like please and [__] next to me
in traffic I turned over and look
there's a dude in SUV laughing and I was
like what the [__] and then he looked at
me and said that motherfucker's laughing
at me I was getting ready to get out of
here I'm [__] yelling at that
[__] I thought he was I thought
he was [__] laughing at me can you
imagine that she would have that yeah
no traffic because of that and he wasn't
even laughing at you no yeah he's
talking like on speakerphone yeah it
wasn't anything he was laughing I was
looking at him when he was laughing and
he looked at me well he probably saw you
out of the court of his stuff like what
is that [__] yeah oh you
laughing at me [__] I'm gonna
kill you yeah yeah he was like oh my God
a crazy person is in the car next to me
yeah
yeah I [__] shook it off though yeah
that's good I was like I probably
imagined it yeah you did yeah you did I
mean
it's not good it's not good I'm just
saying yeah
um but like you to this day I'll [__]
go I think I'm gonna get some trash
can I go stay at a hotel for a while
until you're done
you gotta pay for that [__] it's
probably the most mind-altering one I've
done it's similar to yeah I mean the
other stuff wasn't uh I didn't really
notice any difference like in your
personality but that one I totally did
but like I said I didn't really know
until afterward because she didn't tell
me yeah any of that well you've done a
lot of them too you've done anavar you
didn't notice anything Winstrol you
didn't notice anything no well like that
you haven't noticed anything I don't
well and we've talked about this before
a little bit Yeah but it's just kind of
like we've talked about this before I'm
what they call what or what you said a
weak responder like um and that's always
been true I've always had that um I
don't I don't get sick hardly ever yeah
and I don't respond much to medications
like I don't have any side effects I
don't they don't they aren't really
super effective yeah
um and the same thing happened with all
the stuff you gave I didn't really
notice any personality changes I didn't
notice that much
I mean really the stuff that I'm on now
is the only thing that has actually like
burned fat and like kind of changed my
body composition to any great degree
like other than that like I haven't
really noticed anything and I haven't
really noticed any personality change
you haven't right no no I mean I don't
think I I don't feel any different James
Holmes is saying okay if she hits the
fan [__] I have a tread Trend stash
for that for one yeah yeah I mean in the
apocalypse you'll become like Wes from
[__] road warrior I mean because you
and really it is it is kind of gender
bending in a way because if you see any
male that's weaker than you he he's he's
he you respond to him kind of like like
an ugly female he's not a man around you
you know what I mean you you get you're
weird
well and another thing too is that my
buddy who does gay porn goes on Trend to
do it right you know what I mean yeah
because the weird thing about it is that
the is that the other side of that other
than being like I'm gonna go like rip
people's heads off for like nothing is
that you get like real
simpy yeah like you said yeah I got real
simpy too yeah
and then they come
it's yeah it's like super schizo yeah
real schizo yeah yeah but it's it yeah
but you know you'd be like [__]
talk about [__] that happened like 20
years ago and you feel like all like
[__] you're reliving it upset about
it and [__] is like man I can't believe
I forgot about that right right and it's
like but well one thing and we were
talking about this the other day in the
coffee shop I said I will give Trend
credit for one thing that did seem to
have opened up some
channels in your brain yeah that kind of
like
because now you know and I think that it
wasn't just the trend you get a lot of
empathy yeah like weirdly even though
like don't go on Trend it makes you a
crazy person like it makes pretty much
everybody a crazy person it's very it's
known for that
um but it also did something to you that
you you kind of like because it I don't
know if it was just trying or if it was
some of the other [__] that you were on
but some of the other [__] that you were
on
like if you like progesterone and stuff
like that so you kind of had more of an
experience of not necessarily like what
women are like but kind of almost kind
of like PMS yeah so it's just so and you
kind of retained that because it almost
like it opened up some channels in your
brain yeah so now like when I tell them
some stuff about oh like women think
this or they feel like that like you get
it now I can't understand like before I
would tell you that and you looked at me
like I was a martian yeah um and like a
lot of dudes do well you see
to make it simple you get bombarded by a
bunch of alien emotions when you're a
guy looking at things in a weird ways
and then having emotional reactions to
them that you're not normal it's not
normal to you right well a lot of the
stuff that you're feeling is kind of
like it's a lot of things that you're
seeing is kind of the way women sees it
right on under the because when you
describe it to me I'm like yeah that's
how we are like all the time because
you're under the INF you're you're
you're seeing it you're seeing it a
different way because you have the
influence of hormones that women have
right men don't have a bunch of
progesterone in them no but when you
start dumping a bunch of it in there it
does weird it does it's mind-altering
from a guy's point of view yeah you're
like so now you're seeing things you're
wrong
paranoid like a woman when you describe
it yeah we it's very familiar it was
very familiar to me and like to other
people that you talked to they were like
oh yeah well like we're like that all
the time right
so you know
so I think that it's not like that now
but I understand it when I when I say
yeah because you win you went through it
and so now when I say something it's
like oh I feel this way about it or you
know this is how women feel like you see
about like you get it insecurity and
uncertainty yeah that's like our whole
life yeah
the city men don't really feel it all
that strong I know they don't uh but
when it's frustrating influences like
progesterone insecurity and instability
about life's insecure it affects you it
feels different yeah it feels different
so it Alters your decision-making
process oh yeah a lot more than it would
be if you're a guy yeah a normally a guy
with normal hormone I yeah I feel like
dudes
um in general like I said I would never
speak for everybody because everybody's
different but dudes in general seem a
lot more yeah I'm just gonna do that
they don't really question yeah they're
not really into it they don't yeah they
don't really like read into stuff so
much it's like yeah we're gonna do this
and it's like we're we're confident
about that uh women are not like that at
all the normal male the normal male
setting is
very logical rational kind of like a
methodical and
superficiality kind of machine like it's
a machine like a machine yeah because
that's less stressful and I kind of
guessed that yeah because I'm kind of
more like that than an average woman I
think like I'm more spock-like than an
average woman even my ex-husband used to
go on this Bach so it's not just you
right when you're on Trend you're going
through this and you go wait what is
that other person gonna think right
How's that gonna feel that 40 million
things see me do this what's going to
happen yeah yeah but what happens if
this and what happens with this and
you're thinking of every possible
does this change how people see me if I
do this when you're a dude you don't
give a [__] right that's what I mean but
like I said now you know what it's like
to be us all the time every single
decision of any import
um is gonna be like you have 50
bajillion factors that you're
considering at one time right it's
exhausting I call it being pregnant
Superman yeah yeah because you have that
aspect going which is insecurity yeah
all right and then [__]
hyper overconfidence happening at
exactly the same time which is something
that's not supposed to happen in a
creature yeah so you feel you feel like
a god-like status
yeah you can do anything it doesn't
matter if you even get killed you don't
give a [__] yeah and then there's all
these feelings happening at the same
time then yeah it was super weird it's
all these contradictions happening at
once right so it kind of reminded me of
LSD with mind expansion where you're now
see colors in different ways and you're
conscious your Consciousness is bigger
than it was before there's more things
in it now it's kind of like that yeah
it's just that your emotional bandwidth
is now [__] far broad yes and it's
all happening at once yeah and it just
has to do because all the damn hormones
are I told you well I told you before I
turn off all these [__] brain cells
and [__] I was like you get it now right
yeah
yeah but I also know that it's an
illusion well it's not an illusion
that's the way we experience you're
cheating on me no well I know yeah
there's a lot of [__] that's illusion in
it right you're because you're
overthinking it and you're in your
feelings are not true yeah uh so but see
that's kind of the hell of being me and
like a lot of women are like that too
it's just that a lot of times like you
know it's like you think all these
things it's like could this be true
because but it's like it's just this
constant state of like
uncertainty you're just in a constant
state of uncertainty like all the time I
my perceptions could be wrong you never
ever ever think to yourself or at least
I never do oh my God I'm absolutely 100
right about this never I've never
thought that I don't think in my whole
entire life it's always been like well
maybe maybe not maybe I'm not seeing it
correctly yeah maybe I misinterpreted
this that and the other thing maybe it's
just constant constant in insecurity
like all the time you don't trust your
perceptions you don't trust your
perceptions right ever
which is it's [__] up but that's just
kind of the way it goes you can't really
do much about it I don't know if that's
like genetically wired or if it's
I'm sure it's kind of a combination
probably of being like genetically wired
and being uh you know culturally
enforced but yeah you're never sure
about anything ever ever
so it's it's sucks
uh post that sounds like a psychopathic
learning curve process it was uh it was
super exciting like I said
um I didn't I feel like I didn't really
experience it kind of I don't I don't
want to say this but it's like I didn't
really experience it firsthand because I
didn't know that that's what it was like
I was kind of I'm aware that he's on
stuff obviously because it's like he
gives me stuff too he's like he takes
injections and stuff but I don't really
I didn't really keep track of what he
was on or how long he was on it for so I
didn't know one he didn't tell me ahead
of time that this that it would do that
that it would affect um him that way
because I think he did know but he
didn't tell me he says he did but I
don't remember him telling me
um so either he did tell me and I forgot
which is not likely or he didn't or he
forgot to tell me or he thought he told
me and he didn't which that's I think
that's the most likely scenario but so I
didn't know I didn't know to expect any
of this stuff so when he started acting
like that I had no [__] idea like
what was going on and honestly he didn't
tell me anything until after like I said
he told
um he was talking to Our Friend Sophie
who's been on the show
um she's in the chat sometimes but she's
she's been on the show several times so
he was talking to her and you're like oh
my God like is she cheating on me and
she's just like look it's the trend will
you please calm down but he didn't like
tell me until afterward that all of that
[__] was going on because he was just
going in his man cave and hiding and I
didn't know what was happening I didn't
know until afterward that he had been on
that for five months and I was just kind
of like oh well told me but no
[Laughter]
Zach says basically same thing with me
Jenny I don't know why and I hate it I
hate it too I kind of envy
I don't know if I so much nvx I don't
know if I'd want to be like that I don't
know if I'd want to be like a dude that
was just kind of like yeah I'm just like
confident even if they're wrong which
they are a lot of time but it's just
kind of like oh I'm just gonna do
whatever because I don't give a [__] if
I'm wrong or not because I'm confident
and I'm you know what I don't know if
I'd like to be like that I don't know we
talk about that sometimes because I was
like I'm not saying I'm not a verse
because I was like here's one thing and
maybe this is TMI I said I would like to
have a dick for a day to see what that
was like like we were talking about that
um I said yeah that would actually be
pretty cool
like just for a day to see what it was
like
um but I don't know if I'd want to be a
dude though
I do Envy their overconfidence
but I don't know if I'd want to be like
that
you know what I mean
like as exhausting as it is being me I
don't know if I would want to be
different
you know I don't know it's hard to
explain
it's hard to explain
[Laughter]
uh yeah they're talking about
yeah Zach said I don't know if it's
because I'm gay as well or the autism
but I'm always questioning everything
and I don't like being almost paranoid
like 24 7. yeah I mean I've never we
remember when we did the show about
autism which I think you've recommended
Zach
and I had never really thought about it
before but it's like the more that I
looked at it and it particularly looked
at because girls don't get diagnosed
with autism as much as dudes do because
they
um they don't manifest the symptoms in
the same way but when I looked at the
symptoms I was kind of like oh my God
that kind of sounds like me but you know
I I'm so old at this point it's like I
don't even know if there would be any
[__] reason for me to go and get
[__] I don't think it's the autism I
don't know I'm sure I'm on probably on
the Spectrum somewhere but I think well
the thing about it is that I think girls
are better at hiding it
than dudes are
you know what I mean I think that I
think that's why they don't get
diagnosed as much maybe a little bit of
Aspergers
oh I definitely oh I definitely think I
have Asperger's that's for sure
like at the very least
there's 300 models on is there yep in
our region
William I have to go on yeah
Victor says if I were a woman for a day
I'd have my kitty cat destroyed why
what does that mean
I think it would be fun for a day but I
don't think I would want to be a dude
I don't know I don't think I don't want
to be a dude
because we were talking about this the
other day because I said yeah I wouldn't
mind having a dick for a day just to
like you know [__] around and see what
it was like
then I said would you want to have a
[__] for a day and he said no laughs
he said no
I was like yeah that track
Zach says I kind of wish I could be a
girl mostly because they get to have so
much more fun with clothes and makeup
and hair and stuff a lot more variety
yeah that's true that's true you can't
get away with a lot more
um
you know just in terms of aesthetically
then then you can if you're a dude
dudes clothes are a lot of them are kind
of boring I agree and their hair is kind
of boring less so nowadays but still
you have a lot more leeway
you have a lot more leeway if you're a
girl
um and the post says what's the inherent
big deal about normality
yeah just because it's the norm that
doesn't make it right yeah I absolutely
agree with you on that I don't even know
what that word means
it almost kind of seems like something
oh everybody just agrees upon but I
don't know I don't agree upon it
just everybody should just do what the
[__] they want you know why you're not
hurting anybody I don't give a [__] what
you're doing
I don't think there's no such I don't I
don't think there's any such thing as
normal really especially not now
and I'm totally fine with that
so who's on anybody
whole bunch of people a whole bunch of
people around
busy do you want to hop over to
streamate or or no be a lot of
competition right now well do you want
to not bother
um
we can go on and we can go on tomorrow
90. we can go on a little bit later
there's 290 I mean it's 10 30. you know
that right yeah okay
290 on there
on there I don't wanna we're gonna have
to get off anyway
that's true
I'm kind of hungry actually yeah
that's why I've said that oh okay I
figured it was yeah what did we eat
today we had one patty melt yeah a long
time ago yeah many many hours ago
James says no don't leave
we've been around for like three hours
yeah three hours yeah three hours
we were thinking about jumping back on
stream maid today but I don't know if
there might be too much competition
there's a lot of [__] people there
bored oh [__] yeah
I have to wait till tomorrow then I'm
trying to see uh
trying to see how what percentage of
them are in are in shows yeah I mean
that's always a good thing to look up
because
if there's a lot of people on but hardly
anybody in shows then yeah
then that means there's not much traffic
and it might not be worth it
because like I said a lot of it it's fun
but a lot of it is just kind of like
sitting around sitting around waiting
like waiting for somebody to come in and
like ask you to do something
so we're just kind of like sitting there
listening to music and talking and [__]
be honest you're sitting there waiting
to get picked up like [__] standing on
a lot along the side of a [__] I mean
pretty much Walker yeah pretty much
yeah what did I say I said we should we
should make a sign that says we're not a
sexual charity this is not a sexual
chair
nothing's coming to you trying to get
free [__]
[Laughter]
it's like where we're hoes but we're you
got to pay for those we're not free hoes
yeah you know what I mean see I was
gonna make a difference
oh yeah
she got big boobs too it looks like
Deborah Harry she does a bit you've
never heard his big boobs Tom's checking
out all the competition yeah and what's
funny is that she's uh
she's not she's not in job she's yeah in
the show she's working here putting
makeup on man scaring the [__] out of me
yeah
bad though like when I look at the other
people that are on because I'm just kind
of like man I don't go on my phone or
nothing like that but um
I usually just kind of sit around and
kind of dance to the music and me and
Tom talk and stuff like that but you see
people like [__] sleeping or yeah
just uh scrolling through their phone or
something like that I don't want to do
that but Amy's working oh yeah oh yeah
there she is yeah there she is
but then I look at the other people and
they're doing the same [__] they're just
like kind of hanging out so I don't feel
so bad
because we're always kind of like there
there's kind of a fine line between you
don't want because you want people to
pay so you're like well you don't want
to do anything
um that's gonna like just have them
sitting there like jerking off for free
right so
but you have to still like entice people
in there like to pay oh is she really
yeah she's in a show right now oh okay
well I'm sure she's got me she's famous
so okay um
there's a lot okay a lot of people were
in the shows in the last well looks like
uh one third of them are in shows right
now okay so it's actually
got pretty good
yeah the couples are getting picked up
so actually it's got pretty good traffic
right now okay well look that 18 year
old who's always in there is [__]
into the show she's always there that's
what I was talking about her earlier
yeah she's always just sitting there
like with a goofy face and she's not
like naked or nothing she just like has
regular ass clothes on yeah
[Music]
what are you doing oh she came out she
was actually she was in the cabinet
this is actually uh
we thought that maybe Pinky's pinky
would be on
oh yeah our friend pinky is on there too
yeah
she's got the mega boobs yeah they're
like basketball size you can look around
her name is Pinky Powers Yeah
yeah we used to hang out with her at um
yeah at The Fetish Club Fitness club
Escape
Tammy said I saw a man begging on a
corner the other day he had a sign that
read too ugly to prostitute too honest
to steal okay I probably would have
given that dude buddy I mean at least he
came up with like a funny sign right
that's like pretty awesome
it's pretty funny
yeah so there are a lot of people in
yeah it's it's fairly busy it looks like
okay well we were talking about going on
after the show but like I said I gotta
eat something first because because my
tummy's growling yeah
yeah also we we ate it like a very long
time ago yeah
and we just had like a little sandwich
calorie restriction actually yeah well
like I said I'm not hungry hungry but
I'm kind of hungry and my tummy's kind
of growing I've drank a lot today though
but yeah so we might go hop over to
stream meeting
do some [__] that's right on our way
though yeah James says porn is spiritual
in a way you jerk to a chick and
Visually about what oh what
about that woman you're giving her that
energy you expound okay I kind of see
what you're saying I kind of see what
you're saying yeah right Tom you're
gonna say wait I'm just leaving okay we
gotta wait back up well I gotta get I
gotta get to work yeah you gotta get to
work yeah I can't get to work until the
show ends well we're gonna end it okay
don't get cranky he's gay cranky yeah
he's getting [__] he keeps saying
you're gonna end it
all right we got [__] we gotta do uh
yeah we're gonna eat something then go
over to streamate later and fight around
uh so yeah thanks everybody for dropping
by this evening thanks for super chats
we'll be back on Monday night talking
about a movie I don't know which one yet
because we haven't watched it we'll
watch something over the weekend we'll
talk about it on Monday so we'll see you
guys again on Monday night good